bonjour à tous lors de leur séance de
nuit hier soir les sénateurs ont
poursuivi l'examen de la réforme des
retraites ils ont débattu des articles
16 à 25 qui visent à rendre le système
des retraites plus juste ils ont d'abord
examiné à tout un ensemble de mesures
qui visent à améliorer les retraites des
jeunes actifs et des personnes ayant eu
une carrière heurtée puis ils sont
passés à des mesures concernant les
agriculteurs les petites pensions des
agriculteurs rappelons que François
Hollande alors qu'il était candidat à
l'élection présidentielle avait promis
d'élever à 75% du SMIC la retraite
minimale d'un agriculteur ayant une
ayant eu une carrière pleine la réforme
est encore loin de cette promesse
d'autant plus qu'à Lomé de prévoir de
nouvelles ressources pour le régime des
exploitants agricoles régime pourtant
structurellement déficitaire mais tout
de suite retour à la séance d'hier soir
très bonne matinée sur Public Sénat
nous reprenons la suite de la discussion
du projet de loi adopté par l'Assemblée
nationale après engagement de la
procédure accélérée garantissant
l'avenir de la justice du système de
retraite dans la discussion des articles
nous sommes parvenus à l'amendement
numéro 200 tendant à insérer un article
additionnel après l'article 16 et
l'amendement 200 est présenté par
Monsieur Watrin
par Madame Cohen madame Cohen vous avez
la parole pour la 200 merci monsieur le
président madame la ministre vous l'avez
rappelé vous-même devant l'Assemblée
nationale enfin c'est Madame Touraine je
la cite actuellement la réglementation
prévoit que seule la première période de
chômage non indemnisé est prise en
compte dans la retraite dans la limite
de six trimestres la difficulté vient de
ce que ce délai s'interrompt en cas de
reprise d'un emploi ce qui a une époque
où les carrières sont souvent hachées
est évidemment un obstacle fin de
citation nous partageons évidemment ce
constat à l'heure où les jeunes plus une
position particulière sur le marché du
travail par rapport aux autres actifs
taux de chômage élevé par très important
des emplois de courte durée phénomène de
déclassement salaire faible contenu du
niveau de diplôme ainsi la période
d'insertion des jeunes sur le marché du
travail et marqués par une alternance
entre chômage et emploi précaire par
ailleurs la durée médiane du premier
emploi est d'environ 11 mois d'après les
sources de l'Insee selon une étude du
Trésor en 2009 48,8% des 15 24 ans en
emploi était en contrat temporaire
contre 9% chez les 25-49 ans et
l'ensemble de ces difficultés dans le
processus d'insertion des jeunes sur le
marché du travail se répercutent
forcément sur leur futur retraite dans
une optique d'information nous avons
déposé cet amendement initial
d'information pardon initialement
déposés par la députée carré compte il
présente un réel intérêt car il demande
au gouvernement la remise d'un rapport
qui étudie les modalités de prise en
considération des spécific de l'emploi
des jeunes notamment la possibilité
d'utiliser les premiers trimestres de
chômage non indemnisés de manière
discontinue afin de permettre au mieux
la constitution de droit en dépit d'un
début de carrière heurté madame Touraine
a donc dit à l'Assemblée nationale
contre le retrait de l'amendement que
elle s'engageait à ce qu'il y ait la
publication prochaine d'un décret visant
à prendre en compte ces difficultés pour
éviter qu'une alternance entre chômage
non indemnité emploi aboutissent à
réduire la validation des droits nous
souhaitons par cet amendement mieux
instaurer cet engagement un décret reste
plus à aléatoire en ce sens sous la
disposition peut s'appliquer de manière
différée dans le temps nous en avons eu
hélas de fâcheuse exemples par le passé
et notamment lors du passage de la
réforme de 2010 sous un précédent
gouvernement par cet amendement nous
nous souhaitons que nous nous engageions
ensemble pour
pour les jeunes d'hier et d'aujourd'hui
un avenir beaucoup plus positif j'espère
donc qu'il sera voté par la majorité de
gauche permettant de modifier la donne
je vous remercie merci ma chère collègue
madame la rapporteur avis de la
commission
madame la ministre vous l'avez dit
Madame
Cohen
cet amendement avait été déposé à
l'Assemblée nationale puis avait été
retiré
après que madame la ministre a pris en
séance des engagements sur le maintien
des droits à validation de trimestre
pour les jeunes en chômage non
d'indemnisés donc
nous demandons l'avis du Gouvernement
sur ce amendement et Madame la rapporte
ravie du gouvernement madame la ministre
faire la même demande de retrait madame
Tourette et confirmée la vie du
gouvernement exprimé précédemment par
Madame qui s'est engagée à mettre en
place par décret cette possibilité de
maintien des droits validation de
trimestre pour les jeunes en chômage non
indemnités même au cas de la reprise
d'un emploi donc je confirme cette même
demande et ce même avis
madame Cohen retirez-vous l'amendement
entendre la vie de madame la ministre en
retirant l'amendement puisque j'entends
qu'il s'agit d'un engagement ferme
madame la rapporteur l'a dit donc notre
souhait c'était vraiment d'insister
parce que nous sommes un peu peut-être
défiance sur le fait que parfois les
décrets c'est ce que je disais au niveau
dans le temps c'est un peu différé donc
voilà nous réinsistons et c'était le
sens du dépôt de cet amendement je crois
que madame la ministre est si présente
l'a entendu une nouvelle fois que Madame
harrisol Touraine a été sensible et donc
à partir de là nous retirons cette
amendement vraiment souhaitant fortement
que les engagements pris soit tenus
merci Madame Cohen l'amendement est
retiré je mets aux voix l'article 16 TER
qui est pour son option
qui est pour son adoption qui est contre
abstention l'article sester est adopté à
l'article 17 je suis ici d'un amendement
numéro 418 présenté par Madame de
Montech la rapporteur
s
favorable je mets aux voix l'amendement
de l'explication de votre madame Pasquet
je vous en prie
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre mes chers collègues les
conditions dans lesquelles sont
calculées les droits retraites des
apprentis en l'état actuels du droit ne
sont pas acceptables alors que certains
prétendent faire de l'apprentissage une
voix noble en insistant sur le la valeur
travail en leur impose des conditions
d'acquisition de trimestres qui leur
sont très défavorable en effet il cotise
aujourd'hui sur une assiette forfaitaire
de leur permettant de valider une durée
d'assurance vieillesse égale à celle de
leur contrat la situation n'est pas
anodine puisque comme le rappeler déjà
la Cour des comptes en 2009 les
apprentis de moins de 17 ans lors des
deux premières années de leur contrat
d'apprentissage ne valide respectivement
que depuis trois trimestres ce
âgé de 18 à 20 ans pendant les deux
premières années de leur contrat ne
valide que trois trimestres
ceci s'explique sans doute par le fait
que l'assiette de cotisations sociales
soit dès le début imputé de 11% du SMIC
mais aussi ces cotisations sont
calculées exclusivement sur la partie
professionnelle de l'activité le temps
pendant lequel les apprentis sont dans
l'entreprise ce qui prive mécaniquement
ces derniers de la possibilité d'obtenir
4 trimestres en un an cette situation
est bien évidemment injuste et ce couple
a une faible rémunération je voudrais
rappeler ici qu'en 2010 en lieu et place
du renforcement des droits des apprentis
la droite avait proposé de réduire ses
droits en faisant porter l'assiette
mensuelle forfaitaire de cotisations
pour les apprentis sur
151,67 fois le montant horaire du smic
contre 169 heures mensuelles
initialement une manipulation qui a tout
de même permis d'économiser 72 millions
d'euros dans ce contexte forcée de
constater que l'adoption de cette mesure
constitue une amélioration par rapport
au droit existants même si nous
demeurons persuader que la réforme
d'ampleur que nous devons prendre doit
porter sur la suggettissement et la
cotisation de toutes les périodes et non
pas seulement de celle effectivement
travailler c'est pourquoi avec cette
réserve le groupe C s'absiendra sur cet
article merci ma chère collègues sur
cette amendement
de la rapporteur numéro 418 qui a un
avis favorable du gouvernement qui est
pour s'adoption contre abstention
l'amendement est adopté je mets au veau
à l'article 17 qui est pour contre
abstention l'article 17 est adoptée
article 18 même vote même vote après
l'article 18 amendement 190 rectifié
présenté par Madame Cohen
avec cet amendement nous souhaitons à
l'instar d'autres rapports déjà proposés
au cours de ce débat que le Gouvernement
remet au Parlement rapport évaluant
l'impact financier et le bénéfice pour
les assurer d'un retour à la prise en
compte des 10 meilleurs années de
salaire dans le calcul de la pension des
salariés du secteur privé nous demandons
que ce rapport permettre à cette fin
d'étudier d'autres pistes de financement
existantes et
ignorées jusqu'à présent par le projet
de loi que nous étudions depuis près
d'une semaine à savoir la modulation des
cotisations sociales patronales en
fonction des choix de gestion des
entreprises et de la part des salaires
dans la valeur ajoutée la mise à
contribution des revenus financiers des
entreprises la réception des inégalités
professionnelles et notamment salariales
entre les femmes et les hommes dans la
décennie à venir qui rappelons-le si
elle était effective pourrait rapporter
jusqu'à 10 milliards d'euros d'ici 2020
la réduction du recours au temps partiel
et enfin la sujettissement de tous les
compléments de salaire au cotisations
sociales à la même hauteur que les
salaires la liste de ces pistes que vous
avez malheureusement écarté montrent
combien encore une fois de solutions que
celle de l'allongement de la durée de
cotisation existe alors pourquoi
proposer un tel rapport parce que le
passage des 10 au 25 meilleures années
de carrière pour déterminer le salaire
moyen pris en compte dans le calcul de
la pension décidé lors de la réforme
Balladur de 93 a eu et a un effet
considérable sur le niveau des pensions
selon une étude de 2006 et publiée dans
la revue Population de Linette cette
réforme conduira pour les personnes nées
entre 65 et 74 qui atteindront donc 60
ans entre 2025 et 2039 qui subiront les
effets à plein de cette réforme à une
réduction de la pension moyenne des
hommes de 9% et pour les femmes de 13%.
en effet ce mode de calcul pénalise plus
fortement les carrières courtes et donc
féminines du fait des interruptions et
des réductions d'activités liées
notamment à la maternité pour les
carrières courtes sélectionnées un plus
grand nombre d'années oblige à piocher
permettez-moi l'expression davantage
dans le lot des années avec de plus
faibles salaires du temps partiel ou du
chômage par exemple de plus il faut
souligner que ce sont les effets de
cette mesure de la réforme de 93 qui ont
le plus pesé sur les quarts de pension
entre les femmes et les hommes il paraît
donc tout à fait légitime de sur quoi au
regard des objectifs fixés et enrichi
par nos débats l'article premier de
pouvoir obtenir le rapport que nous
demandons au travers de cet amendement
je vous remercie merci ma chère
collègues madame la rapporteur avis de
la commission
madame la
les auteurs de l'amendement souhaitent
en rapport sur l'impact financier et les
conséquences pour les assurer d'un
calcul des pensions à partir des dix
meilleurs années c'est un sujet qui est
intéressant qui voilà qui qui mérite
d'être opposé il me semble que le
Conseil d'orientation des retraites a
tout à fait sa place pour étudier ce
type de proposition c'est donc un avis
défavorable de la commission de la
commission
merci avis de du gouvernement madame la
ministrement défavorable vous en
conviendrez madame la sédatrice le sujet
était déjà très largement documenté et
les mesures que nous proposons en
direction des salariés qui sont l'objet
de votre préoccupation montrent que nous
avons une option concrète et positive en
leur direction donc avis défavor able
merci madame la ministre je vais mettre
voix cet amendement qui a reçu deux avis
défavorables qui est pour son adoption
qui est contre abstention il n'est pas
adopté après l'article 18 deux
amendements faisant l'objet d'une
discussion commune le premier
d'amendement 177 rectifié présenté par
Madame Pasquet
oui merci monsieur le président madame
la ministre mes chers collègues nous
proposons que dans les six mois suivant
la promulgation de la présente loi par
le nom soit informé du coup pour les
constructions et des conséquences pour
les assurés d'une disposition qui
permettrait aux salariés ayant connu une
carrière professionnelle
particulièrement morcelée de voir
calculer leur salaire de référence sur
Saint trimestre au lieu des 25
meilleures années cette information a
été essentielle au vu des
discriminations dans son victime les
femmes durant leur carrière
professionnelle et qui se prolonge voir
simplifie à l'heure du départ à la
retraite à l'heure actuelle les femmes
bénéficient en moyenne de salaires moins
élevés que ceux des hommes la règle de
validation de trimestre défavorisée les
carrières précaires et mal rémunérées le
mode calcul du salaire de référence sur
les 25 meilleures années bénéficie
surtout au plus aisés et des avantages
les bases salaires
enfin si les périodes de chômage sont
validées ne sont pas considérés comme
cotisés
la délégation au droit des femmes tout
comme la Haute autorité de lutte contre
les discriminations ont présenté de
nombreuses recommandations visant à
corriger ces écarts parmi lesquels la
détermination du salaire de référence
sur la moyenne des 100 meilleurs
trimestres plutôt que la moyenne des 25
dernières années pour mieux compenser
les carrières morcelées et le temps
partiel qui touchent particulièrement
les femmes compte tenu de l'impact
considérable de la précarisation sur le
niveau des retraites notamment des
salariés peu qualifiés et des femmes
cette proposition mérite d'être étudiée
particulièrement dans le contexte actuel
qui avec l'adoption de ce projet de loi
se traduira par une baisse significative
des retraites c'est pourquoi nous vous
proposons d'adopter cet amendement
merci avis de la commission madame la
pardon excusez-moi deuxième amendement
présenté pour Madame Rossignol
l'amendement 320 rectifié de terre
monsieur le Président merci je serai
d'autant plus rapide que le groupe CIRC
il y a eu la gentillesse de reprendre
les amendements de la délégation droit
des femmes et de les signer groupe CRC
et donc d'avoir pour beaucoup d'entre
vous la capacité des signes ainsi deux
fois mon propos sera d'autant plus bref
il s'agit en effet de demander au
gouvernement d'étudier la possibilité
l'impact financier d'un passage des 25
meilleures années au 100 meilleurs
trimestres et j'explique ce que ce que
ça signifie puisque 25 meilleurs
trimestres peuvent être répartis sur
30-35 40 années et donc permet un calcul
du montant des pensions sur une
référence qui peut être plus favorable
et plus proche de la carrière réellement
effectuée par un salarié merci
merci Madame Rossignol avis de la
commission madame la rapporteur
madame la ministre c'est de
pour rendre le rapport puisque dans
l'amendement présenté par Madame Pasquet
c'est ça parce que ouais
j'avais un doute l'amendement présenté
par main parce que stipule que le
gouvernement rendra en rapport dans les
six mois après la promulgation de la loi
alors que le rapport de notre rapport de
la délégation aux droits des femmes
stipule un délai un peu plus long de 18
mois
alors un peu moins jusqu'au boutiste
alors je d'abord première remarque il me
semble que le c'est un sujet dont
pourrait s'emparer le Conseil
d'orientation des retraites mais si
Madame
parceque de retirer son amendement au
profit de l'amendement de la délégation
enfin de leur rapporteur à la délégation
droit des femmes j'aimais un avis de
sagesse
merci madame la ministre
monsieur le Président a fini défavorable
car combien d'entendus la vie de
la Commission du droit des femmes mais
malgré tous les délais reste peu
différent et c'est aussi un sujet qui
examinera que qui a déjà examiné qui
examinera de nouveau le corps donc dans
l'état de nous donnons un avis
défavorable
merci Madame Pasquet
avez-vous entendu la rapporteur
et est-ce que vous maintenez votre
amendement
j'ai entendu la rapporteur je vais
retirer sa main au profit de celui de
Madame Rossignol et j'en profite pour le
répondre que c'est aussi une mesure de
précaution de déposer deux fois
l'amendement vaut mieux deux fois que
que pas du tout je suis désolé que
Madame Rossignol de le prenne mal en
tout cas sachez que nous avons les mêmes
objectifs et je crois que c'est ça quand
même le plus important merci Madame
Pasquet donc
l'amendement 177 rectifié et retiré je
mets aux voix la main en 320 rectifié
terre qui a reçu un avis de sagesse de
la Commission et un avis défavorable du
gouvernement qui est pour son adoption
qui est contre abstention il est adopté
après l'article 18 deux amendements
identiques cette fois faisant l'objet
d'une discussion commune le 180 rectifié
présenté par le groupe communiste par
Madame Pasquier
merci monsieur le Président j'espère que
les autres auteurs ne seront pas blessés
de même
à l'occasion de notre intervention sur
l'article premier nous avons eu un
échange nourri sur les inégalités
salariales et de pension dont les femmes
sont victimes je ne reprendrai qu'un
chiffre qui montre l'ampleur de la
situation la différence de salaire entre
les femmes et les hommes est en moyenne
de 42%, c'était qu'un rappel des
solutions urgentes permettant de
compenser les effets négatifs cumulés
des précédentes réforme comme les
mesures d'allongement des durées de
cotisation adoptées en 1993 2003 et 2010
bien entendu les mesures proposées dans
ce projet de loi comme la prise en
compte des congés maternités pour les
carrières longues l'abaissement de 200 à
150 heures de SMIC pour valider un
trimestre ou la refondation que vous
projetez des droits familiaux pourront
sans doute améliorer à la marge la
situation des femmes
mais cela ne sera pas de nature à
résoudre les inégalités structurelles
dont elles sont victimes je me souviens
pourtant avoir entendu une Najat
Vallaud-Belkacem la ministre des Droits
des Femmes affirmée il faut tenir compte
de l'impact différencier de la réforme
des retraites chez les hommes et les
femmes c'est mon obsession nous
pourrions être d'accord avec cette
affirmation pour autant qu'elle soit
suivie des faits et en réalité en
augmentant la durée de cotisation votre
réforme sera tout aussi insupportable et
injuste pour les femmes que les
précédentes face à ce constat partagé
par l'immense majorité des associations
féministes nous avons proposé des pistes
alternatives comme la surcotisation des
employeurs pour les emplois atteints
partiels ou la suppression des
exonérations de cotisations sociales aux
entreprises qui ne respecteraient pas
l'égalité salariale entre les femmes et
les hommes ces mesures de financement
permettant d'autres solutions que la
logements de la durée de cotisation vous
les avez écartés l'article 40 nous
interdisant de présenter un amendement
permettant de proposer une modification
des conditions de calcul du montant des
pensions nous sommes contraints nous
limiter à une demande de rapport et bien
évaluant l'impact sur le niveau de
pension des femmes et des personnes
ayant eu une carrière heurté d'un
salaire servant de base au calcul de la
pension calculer sur les cent trimestres
les plus avantageux pour l'assurer mais
que le soit clair madame la ministre et
Madame la rapporteur au-delà du support
technique de cette amendement une
demande de rapport c'est bien sûr le
fond de cette proposition que nous
souhaiterions vous entendre
merci Madame Pasquet à m'en demande 338
rectifiés bis présenté par Madame
lippiette merci monsieur le Président
alors actuel dans le régime général sont
prises en compte dans le calcul de la
pension de l'assurer les 25 meilleurs
années or ce mode de calcul pose donc un
problème comme il vient de rappeler pour
les carrières heurtées ou hachées le
salaire de référence annuel d'une femme
sera ainsi altérée c'est au cours de
l'année elle part en congé maternité de
la même façon le salaire du parent qui
choisira de bénéficier du complément de
libre choix d'activité quand je dis
parents c'est une hypocrisie en réalité
c'est dans 80% en 90% des cas l'homme
subira lui aussi une baisse enfin le
chômage aura le même effet pervers
quant à la maternité
au complément de libre choix il faut
remarquer que nos enfants sont ceux qui
vont payer nos retraites et que la
grossesse et la maternité
en quelque sorte baisse les futurs
retraites pénalisent les femmes alors
même que ce sont les femmes qui sont les
seules à être à même pour l'instant du
moins de justement être enceinte et
d'accoucher il nous semblerait donc
particulièrement
utile d'étudier l'impact sur les
carrières orteils notamment pour les
femmes de la prise en compte n'ont pas
des 25 meilleurs années mais des 100
meilleurs trimestres le nomme absolu de
trimestre pris en compte ne bouge pas
simplement à travers toute une carrière
professionnelle on peut ainsi choisir
telle ou tel trimestre dans une année
qui est le plus favorable et exclure les
périodes moins favorables ce pour être
une justice de grande importance pour
les femmes et toutes les personnes qui
ont eu une en prenant réellement en
compte toutes les évolutions de leur
parcours pour plus de justice d'autant
plus qu'il est particulièrement encore
une fois anormal que les femmes soient
pénalisées de mener à bien des
grossesses je vous remercie merci Madame
alors avis de la commission madame la
rapporteur sur ces deux amendements
identiques
mes chers collègues ces deux amendements
sont identiques le 180 rectifié et le
338 rectifié bis mais ils sont aussi
quasiment
identiques
aux deux précédents donc je vous
rappelle que l'amendement 320 a été
votée l'amendement 177 avait été retiré
je vous propose de retirer vos
amendements parce que on a aujourd'hui
dans le texte à la minute où on parle
exactement la même chose qui vient
d'être votée
merci Madame la Ministre avis du
gouvernement
leur rapporteur car en effet le 320
abandon 320 rectifier terre à satisfait
à votre demande en incluant dans un même
amendement les hommes et les femmes et
il ne m'apparaît pas indispensable donc
de faire une redondance sur les seuls
merci Madame la Ministre madame Pasquier
vous avez la parole pour retirer votre
amendement ou pour le maintenir
je prends la parole je vais retirer
l'amendement effectivement par rapport
vous savez quand on dépose des
amendements on n'est jamais bien sûr de
savoir s'il va être adopté ou pas donc
voilà
surtout les notes donc c'est la raison
pour laquelle nous avons cette
amendement pour éduqualifier de repli
m'étant donné que le 320 était adopté
nous allons le retirer merci Madame
parce que de même madame lippiette les
deux amendements sont donc retirés après
l'article 18 amendement 186 rectifié du
groupe communiste présenté par Madame
Cohen vous avez la parole c'est un
rendement a pour objet de demander au
gouvernement de remettre au Parlement un
rapport étudiant les scénarios
permettant de relever le minimum
contributif et la location de solidarité
aux personnes âgées à hauteur du salaire
minimum interprofessionnel de croissance
nette la réforme Fillon de 2003 avait
inscrit dans la loi un objectif de
relèvement du minimum contributif de
façon à porter le minimum de pension
perçue par un assuré social ayant une
carrière complète et ayant liquidé sa
pension au taux plein de 85% du SMIC net
et ce à partir de 2008 cet objectif
progressivement était abandonné il
convient de le réaffirmer et de viser un
niveau supérieur au seuil de pauvreté
celui du SMIC le rapport Moreau précise
que le taux de pauvreté est en net
augmentation chez les plus de 75 ans je
cite 700000 femmes de plus de 65 ans
vivent sous le seuil de pauvreté en
France au sein de la population les
femmes isolées notamment l'évêque sont
surprisés le minimum contributif qui
s'élève à 640 euros par mois comme
l'ASPA dans le montant et de 780 euros
par mois se situe en deçà de ce seuil
une mesure d'augmentation du minimum
contributif aura pour effet direct
d'améliorer le niveau de pension des
femmes et ainsi de réduire l'écart avec
les hommes dans le secteur privé fin
décembre 2011 plus de 4 millions de
retraités 4,9 millions du régime général
perçoivent le minimum contributif dont
70% des femmes dans le secteur public
52,3% des femmes retraitées et 32,6% des
hommes retraités perçoivent le minimum
contributif garanti ainsi si l'on
envisageait des leviers permettant de
relever le minimum contributif c'est une
part importante de la population qui
serait concernée par ce dispositif et en
améliorait ainsi leurs conditions de vie
ce qui nous apparaît plus que nécessaire
merci Madame avis de la commission
madame la rapporteur
le président Mama ministre c'est un
moment prévoit la remise en rapport du
Gouvernement au Parlement sur le
relèvement du minimum contributif et de
la SPA de
l'ASPA jusqu'au niveau du SMIC
on en a déjà discuté à l'occasion
d'autres amendements donc pour les pour
les raisons
identiques aux dernières fois c'est un
avis défavorable de la commission merci
Madame la Ministre même avis même avis
de la part du gouvernement pour la même
merci je vais mettre voix l'amendement
186 rectifié avec deux avis défavorables
qui est pour son adoption qui est contre
abstention il n'est pas adopté article
19 Monsieur Dominique Watrin vous avez
la parole
oui oups CRC votre en faveur de cet
article dans la continuité d'ailleurs de
notre vote de 2010 les niveaux de
pension des conjoints collaborateurs de
chefs d'entreprise soit commercial
artisanal agricole ou libéral sont
tellement faibles que tout doit être
effectivement mis en œuvre pour
permettre une évolution positive je note
d'ailleurs que les conjoints dont il est
question sont plus souvent des
conjointes cette question est souvent
consensuelle dans notre assemblée
j'espère qu'il en sera de même pour cet
article puisqu'il répare de fait une
injustice de taille en effet dans les
tact actuels des choses la filiation
personnelle obligatoire des conjoints
collaborateurs à l'assurance vieillesse
volontaire cesse en cas de divorce ou
lorsque le chef d'entreprise part en
retraite ou décède et que le conjoint ne
reprend pas la direction de l'entreprise
cela revient à dire qu'il ne s'agit pas
d'une affiliation en nom propre que cela
rend les conjoints collaborateurs
particulièrement dépendants le groupe
CRC qui se prononce pour la
défaillarisation de toutes les
prestations sociales ne peut donc
soutenir cette démarche et pourquoi
malgré les limites du dispositif qui ne
permettra pas lui seul d'augmenter
sensiblement les pensions de conjoint
collaborateurs le groupe CRC soutient
cet article merci monsieur wattrelle
nous arrivons à la discussion commune de
quatre amendements madame Cohen
le 205 donc début janvier 2012 le
gouvernement consciente la question des
inégalités de rémunération entre les
femmes et les hommes ne se limitaient
pas à la sphère des grosses entreprises
lancait le site internet et Gap Pro.fr
pour informer les PME et les salariés
sur les enjeux de l'égalité salariale
entre les hommes et les femmes ceci
donne en quelque sorte au TPE et PME une
feuille de route sur la mise en place de
leur nouvelle obligations en matière
d'égalité salariale en insistant sur la
construction d'un diagnostic il faut
dire que depuis le 1er janvier 2012
toutes les entreprises ayant un effectif
d'au moins 50 salariés sont tenus de
négocier un accord collectif relatif à
l'égalité professionnelle pour autant
cette obligation n'est pas étendue aux
entreprises dont l'effectif est compris
entre 11 et 50 salariés
ce qui ne signifie pas pour autant
qu'elle soit exempte de toute critique
en la matière ainsi comme le rappelait à
raison le rapport de notre haute
assemblée sur le projet de loi relatif à
l'égalité salariale entre les hommes et
les femmes dans les TPE un homme employé
à temps complet perçoit en moyenne
1940 euros une femme
1790 soit environ 8% de moins donc il
est extrêmement important que dans
toutes les entreprises effectivement il
y ait une campagne et une politique
plutôt en matière d'égalité que ce soit
un objectif et une ambition importante
et en tout cas c'est ce que porte le
groupe CRC au travers de toutes les lois
que nous examinons et y compris celles
concernant les retraites donc on ne peut
se satisfaire d'une situation où
l'égalité n'est pas respectée de fait
d'autant que les mesures d'augmentation
salariale dont les femmes pourraient
profiter en raison de l'adoption de
notre amendement constituerait un
renforcement financier de leur capacité
à consommer ou tout simplement à vivre
mieux pour toutes ces raisons nous vous
invitons donc à voter en faveur de notre
amendement merci amendement numéro 206
présenté par Madame Pasquet
l'article elle
2242 5 1 du Code du travail indique que
les entreprises d'au moins 50 salariés
sont soumises à une pénalité à la charge
de l'employeur lorsqu'elles ne sont pas
couvertes par un accord relatif à
l'égalité professionnelle ou à défaut
d'accord par les objectifs et les
mesures constituant le plan d'action
défini dans les rapports prévus aux
articles
l232347 et
l232357 très souvent et jusqu'à présent
il faut bien le reconnaître malgré les
nombreuses lois existantes
l'égalité professionnelle et la grande
absente des politiques des entreprises
manque de volontarisme machisme ambiant
les habitudes et les mentalités sont
difficiles à faire évoluer certes la loi
que nous avons adoptée dernièrement sur
présentation de la ministre des Droits
des Femmes peut contribuer à améliorer
la situation mais là encore nous avons
exprimé nos doutes
nous pour nous l'égalité n'a que trop
attendu il n'est plus possible de donner
sans cesse des excuses pour ne pas
appliquer la loi dans les entreprises il
est impératif de franchir un palier
c'est pourquoi l'alinéa prévue dans le
code du travail et permettant une
nouvelle fois aux entreprises d'échapper
à un accord en leur proposant de
constituer un plan d'action qui sera
moins ambitieux ne nous satisfait pas en
effet s'il n'y a pas s'il n'y a pas
accord du fait de l'employeur c'est sans
doute parce qu'il aura estimé que les
mesures proposées sont trop ambitieuses
dans ce cas il est probable que le plan
d'action qui proposera à son initiative
pour échapper à la pénalité sera
forcément adaptée à sa conception de
l'égalité et à sa mise en oeuvre au sein
de son entreprise il est en effet très
peu probable que la corne soit pas signé
par l'employeur du fait de mesure qui
n'aurait pas assez loin quand je dis
cela je ne veux pas caricaturer les
employeurs qui seraient tous de mauvais
élèves en matière d'égalité
je citerai pour cela le palmarès rendu
public il y a quelques jours lors de la
Semaine de l'égalité professionnelle
avec un encouragement adressé à Orange
certes dirigé par un homme mais qui
remporte la palme du classement en
matière de féminisation des instances
dirigeantes mais pour quelques
entreprises prenez enfin conscience des
défis combien de chantiers sont encore
devant nous temps partiel l'évolution de
l'emploi des qualifications de la
formation et des salaires etc
vous me direz que je m'éloigne du projet
de loi pour les retraites mais n'a
absolument pas nous poursuivons notre
logique des choses se dire implacables
c'est agissant en amont qu'on pourra
résoudre les inégalités de pension entre
les femmes et les hommes c'est un
agissant en amont donc sur l'égalité
salariale qu'on pourra dès 2015 dégager
5 milliards d'euros de recettes
nouvelles pour notre système de retraite
et 10 milliards dès 2020 pour nous la
volonté affichée par la ministre des
Droits des Femmes pour une égalité
professionnelle pleine et entière doit
également se traduire dans ce projet de
loi retraite c'est l'un des objectifs de
notre amendement que nous vous appelons
adopter merci ma chère collègues à m'en
demande numéro 209 présenté par Monsieur
Watrin vous avez la parole
oui depuis la loi
83635 du 13 juillet 1983 sur l'égalité
professionnelle entre les hommes et les
femmes dites loi Rudy l'employeur est
tenu dans les entreprises de 300
salariés plus de soumettre chaque année
pour avis au comité d'entreprise ou à
défaut délégué du personnel soit
directement soit si elle existe par
l'intermédiaire de la Commission de
l'égalité professionnelle un rapport
écrit sur la situation comparée des
conditions générales d'emploi et de
formation des femmes et des hommes dans
l'entreprise ainsi au terme de l'article
l232357 du Code du travail ce rapport
doit notamment comporter une analyse
permettant d'apprécier pour chacune des
catégories professionnelles de
l'entreprise la situation respective des
femmes et des hommes en matière
d'embauche de formation de promotion
professionnelle de qualification de
classification de conditions de travail
de rémunération effective et
d'articulation entre l'activité
professionnelle et l'exercice de la
responsabilité familiale il recense par
ailleurs les mesures prises au cours de
l'année écoulée en vue d'assurer
l'égalité professionnelle les objectifs
prévus pour l'année à venir et la
définition qualitative et quantitative
des actions à mener à ce titre ainsi que
les valvaluation de leur coup pourtant
selon le rapport d'information de la
délégation droit des femmes de
l'Assemblée nationale plus de la moitié
des entreprises non pas élaborées de
rapports de situation comparées de même
la halle et la délégation et droit des
femmes au Sénat ont elle aussi émis des
recommandations qui demandent au
gouvernement d'aller plus loin dans cet
objectif
d'équilibre professionnel et salariale
le gouvernement missionne de résoudre la
question des inégalités professionnelles
entre les hommes et les femmes en
sanctionnant les entreprises qui ne se
soumettent pas cette obligation il
s'agir de verser au fond de solidarité
vieillesse à montant égal au maximum 1%
des rémunérations et gains ce montant
serait néanmoins apprécié en fonction
des efforts constatés dans l'entreprise
nous souhaitons au niveau du groupe CRC
elle est plus loin en proposant que ce
taux soit porté à 5%, c'est en effet
avec une loi volontariste et
contraignante que les entreprises
prendront réellement conscience de la
nécessité de parvenir à cette égalité
toujours affichée mais trop rarement
appliqué
merci et le quatrième amendement le
numéro 208 présenté par Madame Pasquet
208 présenté par Madame Cohen dans la
continuité de notre précédent amendement
et pour répondre dans le même mouvement
double défi qui nous est posé à savoir
atteindre l'égalité professionnelle et
donc contribuer à sauver notre système
de retraite nous proposons de doubler la
pénalité qui a un combat à une
entreprise en cas de non-accord en
matière d'égalité quand cette même
entreprise a déjà fait l'objet d'une
sanction
identique dans les quatre années
précédentes pour nous l'objectif de cet
amendement est une nouvelle fois d'avoir
une loi ambitieuse et en accord avec ce
que nous portons toutes et tous dans
cette assemblée du moins je l'espère en
matière d'égalité professionnelle nous
n'avons que trop partagé le constat
d'entreprise qui n'avance pas sur ces
questions par manque de volonté par
idéologie également ne nous en cachons
pas les raisons il existe donc des
entreprises récidivistes à l'instar de
certains partis politiques d'ailleurs
qui préfèrent payer des pénalités plutôt
que de mettre en place des accords
favorisant l'égalité je crois que notre
message doit être clair et ferme et pour
cela le doublement de la pénalité peut
aider à dépasser certaines réticences
voir des résistances le respect des
obligations fixées par la loi doit être
incontournable au risque sinon de se
retrouver dans quelques années toujours
dans la même situation avec des lois qui
se succèdent et des inégalités qui
perdurent et qui même s'approfondissent
les 27% des cas salariales entre les
femmes et les hommes ne sont pas le
fruit du hasard ou le fruit d'une
différence de compétence ils sont le
fruit d'une culture de l'entreprise où
l'égalité passe sans cesse au second
plan où les inégalités sont
intériorisées ou les femmes sont la
plupart du temps dans des fonctions peut
valoriser tout ceci est bien évidemment
entretenu consciemment ou inconsciemment
par des schémas qui sont préétablis ou
le pouvoir est d'abord masculin si l'on
souhaite équilibrer davantage les choses
dans l'intérêt des deux sexes avec un
meilleur partage des fonctions et des
responsabilités que ce soit dans la
sphère privée comme dans la sphère
publique la loi doit être respectée à la
lettre pour qu'elle le soit la pénalité
doit être dissuasive de quelconque
contournement c'est pourquoi nous
proposons son doublement en cas de
récidive et qu'on ne fasse pas des
procès d'intention il s'agit vraiment de
sanctionner les entreprises qui ne
respectent pas la loi et qui continue à
ne pas la respecter et je dirais
continue à l'assumer
merci ma chère collègues madame la
rapporteur avis de la commission sur ces
quatre amendements
présentés par nos collègues vise tous à
pénaliser les entreprises qui n'ont pas
élaboré d'accord ou de plan d'action sur
l'égalité professionnelle entre les
femmes et les hommes qui n'ont même pour
certaines pas fait de rapport comparés
de situations c'est un sujet important
je pense qu'on est nombreux dans ces sur
les bandes de cette assemblée à partager
les constats qui sont faits les analyses
qui sont faites
comment on l'a déjà évoqué à propos
d'autres amendements il y a le projet de
loi sur l'égalité professionnelle entre
les femmes et les hommes qui doivent
revenir en deuxième lecture au Sénat
puisqu'il a déjà été adopté et il va
être discuté à l'Assemblée nationale il
me semble que ces amendements trouveront
davantage leur place dans le projet de
loi égalité professionnelle entre les
hommes et les femmes
dans le projet de loi que nous étudions
actuellement que nous examinons autour
de la retraite autour de la réforme des
retraites sachant qu'on le sait bien ce
qui se passe dans la vie active au
niveau de des salaires liés au travail
ce reporte évidemment sur sur les
retraites et les inégalités constatées
dans le travail sont reporte bien
évidemment et ce constatent bien
évidemment pour les pensions de retraite
néanmoins pour les raisons que je viens
d'évoquer c'est un avis défavorable qui
est donné sur ces quatre amendements
merci Madame la Ministre avis du
gouvernement
défavorable monsieur le Président car
c'est ses amendements relèvent davantage
de la loi que vous avez votée dans cet
assemblée le 17 septembre dernier sur
l'égalité professionnelle faible homme
quant aux 206 il s'y ajoute qu'il
controviendrait au principe garantis par
la constitution de liberté
conventionnelle des favorable merci
Madame la mini je vais mettre au voie
ces quatre amendements et tout d'abord
l'amendement 205 qui a reçu deux avis
défavorables qui est pour son adoption
qui est pour qui contre
si vous voulez alors sur le 205 n'est
pas adopté explication de vote monsieur
Longuet sur le 206
très simplement monsieur le Président
Madame le ministre mes chers collègues
c'est pour signaler comme Madame de
montest la fait avec autorité que si le
sujet mérite réflexion il y aura
d'autres rendez-vous législatifs pour le
traiter donc croyez bien chers collègue
du groupe CRC que nous n'avons pas
d'hostilité de principe à débattre de ce
sujet nous souhaitons simplement le
faire dans un contexte qui permette
d'aboutir or nous serions ici à cet
instant dans un cavalier législatif
alors qu'il y a un sujet de fond qui est
celui des conjoints collaborateurs sur
lequel nous aimerions nous exprimer un
moment du vote de l'article
merci mon cher collègue je me vois
l'amendement 206 qui est pour
contre abstention il n'est pas adopté
amendement 209 même votes même vote à
maintenant 208 même vote même vote nous
passons à l'amendement 210 présenté par
Madame Pasquet
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
mes chers collègues cet amendement a
pour but d'engager une réflexion sur la
situation des veuves d'aide familiaux ou
de collaborateurs d'exploitation
d'entreprises agricoles décédé avant le
31 décembre 2018 en effet lors de la
réforme des retraites de 2010 le
bénéfice de la pension de réversion a
été attribuée dans les seuls cas où le
conjoint est décédé postérieur Man au
1er janvier 2011 aujourd'hui nous devons
porter notre attention sur la situation
de celle dans le conjoint est décédé
avant le 31 décembre 2010 si nous
élargissons le bénéfice de la pension de
réversion à ses veuves certes nous
mettrons fin à une injustice mais
surtout nous répondrons socialement à
des femmes qui vivent pour une grande
majorité dans une situation de grande
précarité
l'article 90 de la loi 2010
1330 portes en réforme des retraites a
bien évidemment répondu à une demande
légitime mais ce texte n'est pas allé
assez loin en posant comme date limite
ce 31 décembre 2010 ce qui exclut de
fait une partie des veuves
nous connaissons tous l'apport de ces
femmes dans le travail quotidien des
exploitants nul ne se hasarderait
aujourd'hui à le contester chacun de
nous dans son département a très
certainement été interpellé sur leur
situation que ce soit par les intéressés
elles-mêmes ou par leur organisation
professionnelle et nous sommes
actuellement démunis pour leur réponse
il est donc temps de faire un nouveau
pas en avant pour la reconnaissance
pleine et entière du statut de ces
femmes dater de reconnaître la place
qu'elles ont tenu au sein des
exploitations nous vous proposons donc
aujourd'hui de poser une première pierre
en demandant un rapport au gouvernement
sur les conditions dans lesquelles les
veuves d'aide familiaux ou de
collaborateurs d'exploitation ou
d'entreprises agricoles décédées avant
le 31 décembre 2010 peuvent obtenir une
pension de réversion ce rapport pourrait
être réalisé d'un premier semestre 2014
et remis au Parlement avant le 30 juin
il nous permettrait ensuite de proposer
en toute connaissance de cause les
conditions d'ouverture du droit à la
pension de réversion afin de répondre au
plus vite à leur demande nul doute que
dans la situation de crise à laquelle
doit faire face notre agriculture cette
avancée serait considérée comme un
message fort dans sa direction
si ma chère collègues avis de la
commission madame la rapporteur vous
avez la parole
madame la ministre chers
que l'article 13 bis porte sur un
rapport sur les pensions de réversion
donc il me semble que votre amendement
est satisfait pour autant on va demander
la vie du gouvernement
du gouvernement madame la ministre du
gouvernement monsieur le Président a
défavorable les membres des familles
ayant exercé une activité non salariée
agricole avant le 1er janvier 2011 n'ont
pas pu ouvrir de droit en retraite
complémentaire obligatoire les conjoints
survivants de ces personnes ne peuvent
donc prétendre la réversion de droit qui
n'était pas mise en oeuvre au moment du
décès et pour cette raison de manière
logique le Gouvernement est défavorable
à un rapport sur ce sujet
merci
je vais mettre voix l'amendement numéro
210 qui est pour
pardon je vous en prie Monsieur
je reviendrai pas sur le fond de cet
article je voudrais simplement faire une
remarque de forme qui est quand lie m'a
sauté aux yeux les gars qui correspond
pas dans la rédaction d'amendement à
l'explication dans l'objet on parle dans
lesquels les veuves d'être familiaux et
ensuite dans les lignes explicatives on
parle que le plus souvent le conjoint
est une femme je pense que si le
rédacteur de l'abonnement avait été
cohérent il aurait dû simplement
indiquer dans lesquels les veuves ou
veuf d'être familiaux parce que même si
c'est pas très courant un homme peut
être un ayant droit d'un collaborateur
d'exploitation d'un aide familial donc
c'est une simple remarque de forme mais
je crois que là la démarche est un peu
trop axée et je reviens aussi à la
position du rapporteur on a déjà voté un
rapport sur la réversion on va pas
encore rajouter un énième rapport
merci alors je mets aux voix
l'amendement 210 qui est pour son
adoption
qui est contre abstention il n'est pas
adopté je mets aux voix l'article 19 qui
est pour
qui est contre abstention l'article 19
est adopté nous en venons à l'article 20
avec Madame Emery Dumas qui demande à
prendre la parole sur article vous avez
la parole ma chère collègue
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
mes chers collègues le chapitre que nous
apporte que nous abordons est important
et fait sens pour nos départements
ruraux depuis plus d'un demi siècles le
secteur agricole a connu de nombreuses
mutations et il était plus qu'urgent de
réformer le système de retraite des
exploitants et dénon salariés des
engagements très précis ont été pris par
François Hollande en début d'année 2012
et ils sont ici concrétisés ce projet de
loi est une avancée significative pour
800 000 salariés retraités non agricoles
non salariés agricole pardon et répond à
un impératif de justice les retraites
agricoles étant actuellement en moyenne
inférieure de 40% à celle des autres
indépendants
étendre la retraite complémentaire
obligatoire au conjoint et aux aides
familiaux en attribuant des points
gratuits aux personnes qui sont
actuellement retraités supprimer la
durée minimale d'activité pour
bénéficier des majorations rattraper le
seuil de 75% du SMIC pour les chefs
d'exploitation
assurer la réversion de la retraite
complémentaire obligatoire appliquez le
principe des droits combinés au
retraités qui bénéficient de la retraite
complémentaire obligatoire et accorder
le bénéfice de retraite proportionnelle
aux périodes de longues maladies ces 6
engagements du Président de la
République sont tenus dans les articles
20 à 22 du projet de loi il constitue un
volet très important de cette réforme
car ils contiennent des avancées
concrètes pour les retraités dont on
sait qu'il ne perçoivent à l'heure
actuelle que des pensions extrêmement
faibles c'est d'autant plus vrai pour
les conjoints de regretter agricoles qui
sont le plus souvent des conjointes et
qui ne vivent dans nos départements
ruraux qu'avec quelques centaines
d'euros par mois
le montant des retraites versées au non
salariés agricoles est un des plus bas
de tous les régimes sociaux les causes
en sont connues le refus de la
profession des exploitants agricoles
d'être alignés sur le régime des
salariés lors de la création du régime
général une assurance une assurance
vieillesse obligatoire plus tardive des
cotisations basées dans un premier temps
sur un revenu cadastin de souvent très
faible le manque de statut des conjoints
et l'absence de cotisations vieillesse
pour les aides familiaux ce sont autant
de raisons qui justifient des mesures
présentées
l'article 20 en ce qui le concerne
modifie les conditions d'éligibilité à
la pension majorée de référence pour les
non salariés agricoles en supprimant
l'obligation d'avoir à justifier d'une
durée d'assurance de 17 ans et demi cet
article porte une partie des
revendications des petits paysans qui
vivaient de la polyculture sur des
exploitations familiales c'est leur voix
que je souhaite porter aujourd'hui en me
félicitant des projets indéniables qui
sont portés par ce projet de loi
je vous remercie merci ma chère
collègues je passe la parole à Monsieur
Dominique Watrin pour le groupe CRC
l'article 22 de ce projet de loi suscite
quelques interrogations de la part de
notre groupe tout d'abord il se fixe
pour objectif
d'attribuer des points de retraite
complémentaire obligatoire aux
exploitants retraités dont les pensions
sont les plus faibles afin que le niveau
de celle-ci atteignent d'ici 2017 75% du
SMIC bien qu'apparemment généreuse cette
disposition nous interroge puisqu'en
2003 la réforme introduite par Monsieur
Fillon prévoyait un objectif plus
ambitieux savoir qu'aucune retraite ne
devait être inférieure à 85% du SMIC dès
lors la référence dans cet article au
75% nous apparaîtrons recul même si nous
comprenons la volonté du gouvernement
d'améliorer réellement le montant des
pensions agricoles par ailleurs si nous
avons bien compris que cet article avait
pour objet d'instituer un complément
différentiel de points dans le cadre le
régime complémentaire obligatoire et si
l'étude d'impact nous précise que cette
mesure aura un coup d'environ 72
millions nous ne sommes pas parvenus à
comprendre ni à les lectures de l'étude
d'impact ni de celle du projet de loi ou
du rapport comment était financé ce
régime différentiel enfin si l'objectif
de renforcer les pensions est un
objectif loible que nous soutenons
pourquoi avoir fait le choix de la
création d'un mécanisme différentiel sur
le régime complémentaire obligatoire
plutôt que sur le régime obligatoire de
base aussi compte tenu de ces
interrogations vous comprendrez que sans
réponse satisfaisante à nos questions le
groupe CRC serait contraint l'abstention
merci je passe la parole à Monsieur
Pierre Camani pour le groupe socialiste
oui monsieur le Président Madame la
ministre nous arrivons à un moment
important du débat sur le projet de loi
de réforme des retraites les articles 20
à 22 réalisent des avancées importantes
des avancées nécessaires des avancées
indispensables pour les retraités
agricoles qui se battent pour une
revalorisation de leur pension des
avancées concrètes pour celles et ceux
qui perçoivent à l'heure actuelle des
pensions parfois extrêmement faibles et
cela a été rappelé ces articles sont
importants car peu de progrès ont été
réalisés ces 10 dernières années en
faveur de tes territoricole et il faut
le souligner ces avancées nous les
devons au long combat des retraités
agricoles menés par leurs associations
locales et nationales nous le devons
aussi à la mobilisation des élus des
départements ruraux et je veux saluer le
travail du député germinal Peyrot elles
sont en fines dues à l'engagement du
personnel du Président de la République
sur ce sujet elle se traduise par un
plan d'action qui va se décliner tout au
long du quinquennat dès le premier des
droits seront attribués au conjoint il y
a de familiaux au titre des années
antérieures à la création du régime
obligatoire à partir de 2015 et de
manière progressive jusqu'à 2017 une
pension minimale de 75 % du SMIC sera
garantie pour une carrière complète
l'objectif de l'apéro de 2002 sera enfin
appliqué par ailleurs la condition de 17
ans et demi de cotisations pour
bénéficier de la pension majorée de
référence sera supprimée la réversion de
la RCO sera étendue et le dispositif de
droits combinés au régime complémentaire
sera étendu ce sont là des avancées
importantes même si elles peuvent être
considérées comme encore insuffisantes
par les intéressés mais au-delà des
avancées financières ces trois articles
sont importants pour ne retêter à
l'école
le sentiment d'être pris en
considération par les pouvoirs publics
je vous assure que la non prise en
compte de cette problématique par les
gouvernements précédents c'est dix
dernières années à profondément affecter
ces retraités qui ont le sentiment
d'être laissé pour contre notre société
alors qu'ils ont largement contribué au
redressement de la France après la
dernière guerre et au développement
extraordinaire de notre agriculture
merci mon cher
collègue pas notre demande de prise de
parole je mets aux voix si pour
explication de vote monsieur avant de
mettre au veau à l'article 20 monsieur
Longuet vous avez la parole oui en effet
merci monsieur le Président Madame le
ministre mes chers collègues sur cet sur
cet article 20 il n'y a pas d'amendement
donc mes collègues sont intervenus sur
l'article je voudrais expliquer la
position du groupe de l'UMP au moment de
voter et notre attitude sera une
abstention non pas que l'article 20 ne
représente pas cher collègue vous l'avez
dit avec raison une avancée puisqu'il
s'efforce de mettre en oeuvre un
objectif que la loi de 2003 avait fixé
mais en effet n'avait pas pu atteindre
donc sur le fond il n'y a pas de
malentendu c'est bien dans cette
direction qu'il faut cheminer
simplement la question du financement de
ces mesures n'est pas clairement
identifiée on peut même dire qu'elle
n'est pas identifiée du tout ce que nous
savons du PLFSS à cet instant nous
laisse à penser que le financement de
cette revalorisation des retraites
minimum de l'agriculture sera assurée
par des prélèvements sur les seuls
recettes du monde agricole et en
particulier sur les recettes de
l'exploitation collective je pense
notamment principalement au Gaec et
c'est à cet instant que que nous sommes
préoccupés et que nous ne pouvons pas
partager votre optimisme et votre
enthousiasme comme l'a fait remarquer
d'ailleurs avec raison monsieur Watrin
car s'il s'agit de faire payer une
revalorisation des retraites agricoles
par les seuls revenus agricoles
d'aujourd'hui on est quand même signalé
une forme d'injustice
qui est lié aux démographies relative du
monde paysan et de la société française
au début des trentes glorieuses de
mémoire dans les années 50 les
agriculteurs le monde paysan au sens
large représentait sans doute 20% des
actifs aujourd'hui ces effectifs sont
inférieurs à 3%. cela veut dire que le
monde agricole a contribué d'une façon
décisive par l'exode rural d'une part et
par les donc les agriculteurs
exploitants ou salariés agricoles ou
aide familiaux ont quitté les
exploitations pour assurer le
développement de l'industrie et des
services leurs enfants et se sont en
général des familles en moyenne plus
nombreuses que les familles de salariés
de l'industrie ou des services sont
devenus des salariés de l'industrie ou
du service c'est-à-dire cotisant au
régime général en un mot le monde
agricole a abondé au plan démographique
et je reviens toujours à ce concept
d'équilibre démographique à abonder très
largement le monde du salariat
industriel ou des services faisant
permettant ainsi une réduction des
effectifs sans doute une productivité
une indépendance agricole des réussites
à l'exportation agricole mais enfin
priant les vieux agriculteurs de
recettes qui auraient permis depuis
longtemps d'améliorer la situation des
retraités de l'agriculture alors je sais
que le babsa de le vieil mémoire a
permis de par la compensation
démographique d'apporter un soutien aux
retraites agricoles mais aujourd'hui ce
qui semble apparaître des informations
dont on dispose à cet instant du PLFSS
et je me retourne vers mon collègue j'en
ai le cardo qui a suivi plus
particulièrement sujet et bien c'est que
ce seront les agriculteurs et les
revenus agricoles existants qui
apporteront l'essentiel du financement
de ce complément alors qu'au nom de la
solidarité nationale et en particulier
de la compensation démographique il lutt
normal qu'une partie certes soit
financée par les agriculteurs
d'aujourd'hui mais que l'essentiel soit
financée au titre de la solidarité
puisque c'est le monde agricole qui par
ses transferts massifs d'actifs
agricoles qui ont quitté ce secteur ont
permis pendant longtemps et aujourd'hui
encore le financement des retraites des
vieux salariés du secteur industriel ou
du secteur de service
merci mon cher long mon cher je
collègues j'ai mon cher collègue
excusez-moi monsieur Languet je passe la
parole à Monsieur valorenberg
oui merci monsieur le président madame
la ministre mes chers collègues
effectivement notre groupe est aussi
très sensible à ces mesures qui sont
prises en faveur du monde agricole des
exploitants et des non salariés
agricoles dans les trois articles 20 21
et 22 je m'exprime là pour l'ensemble de
ces mesures avec effectivement la même
remarque c'est que nous venons
d'entendre sur plusieurs banques c'est
comment cela va-t-il être financé et
j'aimerais entendre évidemment madame la
ministre nous répondre à cette question
ce que il s'agit bien sûr ici de
l'équilibre des régimes de retraite donc
les mesures qui sont très favorables à
cette catégorie on le sait aujourd'hui
on peut le dire maltraiter au niveau des
pensions
nous y souscrivons à condition d'y voir
clair alors est-ce que ne serait pas
finalement le gel des pensions par la
non indexation ou le recul le retard
d'indexation de ces pensions de la
revalorisation autrement dit de ses
pensions qui contribueraient au
financement notamment de ses pensions
agricoles c'est une question que je pose
sur laquelle j'aimerais avoir votre
éclaircissement merci beaucoup merci mon
cher collègue pas d'autres demandes
d'explication de vote monsieur Boyer
vous avez la parole
le Président c'est
l'ancien agriculteur qui vous parle il
n'avait pas prévu le faire mais très
simplement il voudrait vous dire que
cette prise en compte des retraites du
monde agricole n'est pas un privilège
c'est une parité parce que vous l'avez
dit président Hongrie un certain moment
l'agriculture représentée après la
guerre 80% la population française il y
a eu les érosions les restructurations
d'exploitation il y a eu les
agriculteurs qui n'ont pas regardé le
nombre d'heures je crois que aujourd'hui
dans nos sociétés se sont eux monsieur
le Président Monsieur les ministres qui
émarge le plus au fond tu vois il a été
vieillesse et vous savez que les
conséquences de remboursement même qu'on
n'est pas beaucoup de bien que ces
agriculteurs et capitalisés représentent
un risque mais il faut rendre César ce
qui appartient cette parité à l'égard
des agriculteurs doit on doit y être
sensible mais il reste quand même sur le
Président chers collègues les épouses
agriculteurs celles qui ont été des
partenaires fidèles à assurer la traite
à assurer l'alimentation de la famille à
bûcher à faire les chars de foin et je
crois que il n'y avait pas
malheureusement une une couverture
sociale qui permettait un autre avantage
chers amis il y avait vous le savez sans
aucun doute les petites exploitations
qui étaient au forfait au forfait quand
on était au forfait je l'ai été un
certain moment on était à des revenus
bas et puis il y a eu à la comptabilité
réelle ou c'est davantage actualisé aux
exploitations mais cette comptabilité
réelle monsieur le Président elle
remonte à pas très longtemps donc je
crois que ce qui est fait en faveur des
agriculteurs n'est pas un privilège
c'est une parité c'est de rapprochement
de parité mais qui doit être aussi prise
en compte
merci mon cher collègue y a-t-il
d'autres demandes d'explication de vote
je n'en vois pas je mets aux voix
l'article 20 qui est pour son adoption
qui est contre abstention
l'article 20 est adopté article 21 même
vote même vote article 22 même vote même
vote après l'article 22 en arrivant à la
mort de mon 342 rectifiés présentés par
Madame lippiette
merci monsieur le Président
ce premier amendement
c'est sur les retraites des agriculteurs
concernent l'assurance vieillesse
agricole et vise à rendre plus juste le
niveau de des cotisations alors que le
système actuel est prévu par palier donc
avec des sauts nous proposons qui
deviennent proportionnels aux revenus en
renvoyant l'application exacte
dispositif à un décret initialement la
méthode actuelle visée à faire jouer la
solidarité entre les agriculteurs elle
est devenue une source
d'évaporation ou d'évasion fiscale les
agriculteurs ayant tendance à
sous-déclarer une partie de leurs
revenus pour ne cotiser qu'au niveau du
début de palier finalement ce sont ceux
qui ont des revenus juste au-dessus du
palais donc au niveau de l'effet de
seuil qui contribue le plus aux
retraites en fonction de leurs revenus
je vous rappelle que la retraite moyenne
d'un exploitant agricole est seulement
de 800 euros par mois juste au-dessus du
minimum vieillesse
il est donc nécessaire de s'adapter aux
pratiques et de réviser dans le sens
d'une cotisation proportionnelle cette
disposition injuste et aussi que l'autre
productif pour les finances publiques
qui fait reposer l'effort sur les plus
fragiles en épargnant pardon les plus
aisés monsieur Issoudun rapporteur à
l'Assemblée nationale avait indiqué à ma
collègue députés Brigitte Alain que le
financement des mesures de justice dans
le domaine agricole était à se réassuré
par un article du PLFSS comme vous le
savez cet examen a eu lieu à l'Assemblée
nationale et mes collègues écologiques
ont naturellement redéposé ses
amendements cependant ceci ont été
balayés d'un revers de main sans aucune
ou sans beaucoup d'explications ou du
moins des explications peu convaincantes
nous profitons donc de cette occasion
pour défendre à nouveau notre conception
de la justice dans le domaine des
retraites agricoles en redéposant ses
amendements je vous remercie merci chers
collègues avis de la commission madame
la rapporteur
oui monsieur le Président Madame la
Ministre chers collègues les questions
financement des mesures concernant les
retraites agricoles ne sont pas traitées
dans ce projet de loi sur les retraites
mais dans le projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale et en
particulier à son article 9
c'est amendement il y aurait donc sans
doute plus sa place sur le fond faut-il
remettre en position les modalités
actuelles de cotisation des non salariés
agricoles sans en avoir évaluer les
conséquences financières et sans avoir
discuté avec les représentants du monde
agricole surtout cet amendement concerne
à l'article qu'il vise l'assurance
vieillesse complémentaire facultative
dans la cotisation est déjà
proportionnelle par le régime
d'assurance vieillesse obligatoire des
non salarié des agricoles enfin cette
mesure relève du pouvoir réglementaire
en effet l'instauration d'une
proportionnalité des cotisations entre
dans ces compétences c'est donc un avis
défavorable
il y avait du gouvernement madame la
ministre
défavorable également je mets aux voix
l'amendement 342 rectifier qui est pour
son adoption qui est contre abstention
il n'est pas adopté après l'article 22
amendement 343 rectifiés présentés par
dame lippiette merci monsieur le
Président dans la même ligne que le
précédent cet amendement propose de
supprimer le plafond de cotisation
maximale pour l'assurance vieillesse
individuelle et agricole aujourd'hui
nous faisons face à une rupture
d'égalité flagrante dans des cotisations
dans le monde agricole en effet un
assuré social avec un revenu annuel de
50000 euros ne cotise que sur une
assiette de
37032 euros la proport la proposition
est ce projet de loi cette amendement
vise donc à rétablir la justice sociale
en mettant fin au phénomène de
sous-cotisation pour les hauts revenus
dans le contexte budgétaire actuel cette
proposition a également pour conséquence
de dégager des fonds qui viendraient
abonder les recettes de mutualité
sociale agricoles il s'agit donc d'une
mesure de justice la distorsion est
criante comme nous le verrons lors de
d'autres examens d'autres amendements
d'un côté un plancher pénalise les plus
petits revenus souvent inférieur au SMIC
mais souvenez-vous à des prélèvements du
fait du mode de calcul de ce plancher de
l'autre un plafond avantage les hauts
revenus nous soutenons évidemment la
revalorisation des retraites agricoles
proposées par le gouvernement mais ça ne
peut se faire sans rétablir une certaine
forme de justice dans le financement
afin que chacun cotise en fonction de
ses revenus je vous remercie merci ma
chère collègues avis de la commission
madame la rapporteur vous avez la parole
monsieur
le président de la ministre
notre collègue aujourd'hui l'assiette
des principales cotisations de retraite
agricole est limitée au plafond de la
sécurité sociale cela s'explique par la
faiblesse du revenu moyen dans ce
secteur de notre économie il existe
toutefois également des cotisations des
plafonnées le col le code rural ouvrant
cette possibilité c'est le cas pour le
financement de la part proportionnelle
de la pension de base des non salariés
agricoles plus généralement le choix a
été fait de traiter la question du
financement des mesures spécifiques au
monde agricole dans le projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale c'est
un avis défavorable
merci avis du gouvernement
défavorable également je mets aux voix
lamentements 343 rectifiés qui est pour
son adoption contre absence abstention
oui pour contre abstention il n'est pas
adopté après l'article 22 à m'en demande
204 rectifiés qui est présenté par
Madame Cohen
mais à part ça tout va bien par arrêter
du 6 avril 1976 pris dans le cadre de la
loi de généralisation
72-1223 du 29 décembre 72 l'accord du 8
décembre 61 était étendue au département
d'outre-mer notons juste le temps qu'il
aura fallu pour l'extension 15 ans par
ailleurs c'est arrêté à concerner les
branches d'activité dans les
travailleurs sont assujettis à titre
obligatoire à l'assurance vieillesse du
régime général de sécurité sociale et je
cite le texte à l'exclusion de celle
visée au second alinéa de l'article L2
du code de la sécurité sociale sont
ainsi visés les professions agricoles et
forestières celles-ci ne sont donc pas
intégrés dans cette extension outre-mer
et pourtant elle relève bien du régime
général de sécurité sociale nous devons
préciser qu'en Guyane un accord a été
signé le 23 avril 99 cet accord a permis
de faire bénéficier à titre obligatoire
et salariés agricoles d'un régime de
retraite complet en complémentaire
néanmoins les autres entreprises
agricoles outre-mer sont seulement
autorisés à adhérer et à affilier
volontairement leur salarié rappelons un
élément l'outre-mer connaît un très
faible niveau dans le montant des
pensions des retraités agricoles ce
n'est pas acceptable il s'agit donc
d'étudier la généralisation de la
retraite complémentaire des salariés
agricoles dans tous les départements
d'outre-mer le but étant bien évidemment
de les faire bénéficier moyennant
cotisations d'une allocation de retraite
complémentaire garantit en plus de la
location versée par le régime de base
autre précision dans l'outre-mer
n'existe pas la SA ce qui fait que c'est
la quête générale de sécurité sociale
qui gère le régime des exploitant et des
salariés agricoles l'instauration d'un
régime de retraite complémentaire
obligatoire pour les salariés agricoles
des dômes à l'exception de la Guyane
pour des raisons précédemment évoquées
nécessiterait donc que les partenaires
sociaux s'accordent sur le principe
d'une affiliation volontaire à l'Arco et
que cet accord soit étendu élargi selon
la procédure prévue aux articles l911-3
et l911-4 du code de la sécurité sociale
par les ministres chargés de la sécurité
sociale et du budget cette négociation
pourrait alors aboutir à un accord de
branche réunissant l'ensemble des
professionnels du domaine c'est le sens
de cet amendement un abondement de bon
sens qui vise à réparer une injustice
qui perdure depuis trop longtemps on ne
comprendrait pas madame la ministre que
vous n'acceptiez pas cet amendement que
votre collègue Victorin Lurel
aujourd'hui ministre des Outre-mer avait
porté haut et fort en 2010 quand il
était encore député de Guadeloupe je
vous remercie
merci ma chère collègue David la
commission
quand même une question extrêmement
importante l'absence de retraite
complémentaire pour les salariés
agricoles outre-mer à laquelle
d'ailleurs une réponse doit être
apportée c'est la raison pour laquelle
s'il n'est pas s'il n'est peut-être pas
nécessaire de réaliser un rapport
supplémentaire il me semble utile
d'entendre les explications que le
gouvernement apportera aux auteurs de
l'amendement je demande donc l'avis du
Gouvernement merci madame la ministre
monsieur le Président
est en effet inutile le problème est
bien identifié les régimes de retraite
complémentaire obligatoire des salariés
y compris agricoles sont institués par
voie conventionnelle au moyen d'accord
d'ationnaux
interprofessionnel étendu et élargi les
salariés agricoles des tomes devraient
être affiliés à agir et à l'Arco au même
titre que les salariés agricoles de
métropole mais la seule solution est que
les partenaires sociaux conviennent d'un
accord pour y parvenir
merci je vais mettre au vol amendement
204 rectifié madame Cohen pour
explication de vote
une explication de votre parce que si
tout le monde reconnaît qu'il y a un
problème je trouve que la réponse du
gouvernement est quand même un petit peu
superficiel parce que je pense qu'il
faut que nous prenions des mesures pour
faire en sorte que les travailleurs
d'outre-mer puissent bénéficier
effectivement des mêmes droits et on
voit bien qu'il y a un retard
considérable donc là j'ai plus
l'impression qu'on botte en touche
plutôt qu'on règle les problèmes alors
je sais pas si c'est le rapport qui peut
faire les choses mais en tout cas ça
pointe les problèmes et la volonté
politique de s'en sortir
merci je vais donc mettre au doigt à
l'amendement 204 rectifié qui est pour
son option
qui est contre abstention il n'est pas
adopté nous en arrivant à l'article 23
et sur l'article 23 madame Claire-Lise
Campion a demandé la parole
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre mes chers collègues avec ce
chapitre 5 nous abordons de nouvelles
mesures de solidarité en faveur des
assurés handicapés de leurs aidants le
projet de loi comprend des mesures très
positives qui valorisent tant les
périodes d'activité des assurés
handicapés que la mobilisation à leur
côté de leurs proches leurs aidants qui
sont souvent contraints de mettre entre
parenthèses leur propre carrière
professionnelle les travailleurs
handicapés ont actuellement la
possibilité de liquider leur retraite à
taux plein dès 55 ans à trois conditions
une durée de travail suffisante une
durée de cotisation suffisante et enfin
un taux d'invalidité égal à 80%, ou la
reconnaissance de la qualité de
travailleurs handicapés la RQTH le
projet de loi madame la ministre modifie
ce dernier critère et permet à ceux qui
ont un taux d'invalidité de 50% de
bénéficier de cette mesure de justice
c'est une avancée réelle il supprime en
parallèle le critère de la RQTH
l'Assemblée nationale a donné une
souplesse au dispositif en reportant la
suppression de la RQTH au 31 décembre
2015 deux systèmes vont donc coexister
jusqu'au 1er janvier 2016 et plusieurs
questions se posent qu'en est-il des
personnes qui handicapées qui
prévoyaient d'invoquer la RQTH au moment
de leur départ en retraite après la date
du premier janvier 2016 est-ce que les
modes de preuve du taux d'incapacité de
50% au moins seront assouplis de telle
sorte que ceux qui ont obtenu la RQTH
puissent ne pas être lésés enfin il
demeure la question de ceux qui n'ont
pas demandé l'attribution d'un dos
d'incapacité en temps utile et ne
peuvent plus ensuite fournir la preuve
d'un taux d'incapacité de 50%. d'autres
modalités de preuve de ce taux
d'incapacité madame la ministre
sont-elles envisagées les personnes
souffrant d'un handicap lourd apparu
apparu tardivement ou d'un handicap qui
évolue avec l'âge sont pénalisés car
elles ne satisfont pas aux règles
concernant la durée de cotisation pour
bénéficier de la retraite anticipée des
travailleurs handicapés leur situation
doit également être prise en compte
merci madame la ministre sur toutes ces
questions importantes de nous apporter
des précisions qui sont attendues
si ma chère collègue la parole est à
madame Isabelle Pasquet pour le groupe
CRC
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
mes chers collègues par un courrier en
date du 23 octobre dernier Monsieur
Dominique baudiste Défenseur des droits
vous inviter à réviser l'article 23 de
ce projet de loi de telle sorte que soit
assoupli les conditions pour pouvoir
bénéficier d'une retraite anticipée des
travailleurs handicapés
dans ce courrier dans la note qui était
jointe Défenseur des droits vous alerter
sur le fait que dès 2006 le président
gouvernement face à l'impossibilité dans
laquelle se trouvait des personnes en
situation d'apporter la preuve du taux
d'incapacité de 80%
des voies parallèles de reconnaissance
du handicap ont été mises en place
soit sous la forme d'équivalence avec
par exemple la reconnaissance d'un taux
d'invalidité par la Sécurité sociale
soit par le biais de la reconnaissance
de la qualité de travailleurs handicapés
le Défenseur des droits constatant que
cette mesure avait été prise afin
d'étendre ce dispositif et de permettre
au maximum de personnes en situation de
handicap de bénéficier de ce dispositif
c'est avec ce même souci que défenseur
des droits analyser cet article 23 le
conduisant à vous formuler une
proposition et précise modifier
l'article 23 afin de permettre l'accès à
la retraite anticipée à tout assurer
handicapé justifiant sur la période
d'assurance requise d'une reconnaissance
administrative de handicap ce qu'elle et
ce quel qu'en soit la forme ainsi une
personne en situation de handicap
pourrait produire à la pluie de cette
demande tous les justificatifs en sa
possession attestant d'un handicap soit
par des instants spécialisés comme les
MDPH ou hier la COTOREP soit par la
Sécurité sociale ou encore par la MSA
cette proposition que nous avons
formulée par voie d'amendement aurait le
double avantage de faciliter réellement
les démarches des personnes en situation
de handicap et mieux reconnaître leur
situation puisque ne serait pas pris en
compte uniquement le taux d'incapacité
permanente même diminuer mais l'ensemble
des situations de handicap viser à
l'article l14 du code de l'action
sociale et des familles naturellement
nous espérons que cet amendement sera
adopté les deux s'en sort dépendra le
vote de notre groupe sur cet article
merci ma chère collègue je passe la
parole à Madame Laurence Cohen
monsieur le Président Madame la Ministre
madame la rapporteur mes chers collègues
cela a été dit l'article 23 de ce projet
de loi modifie les conditions d'accès à
la retraite anticipée des travailleurs
handicapés en l'ouvrant aux assurés
justifiant d'un taux d'incapacité
permanente d'au moins 50 % ainsi que de
manière temporaire aux personnes en
situation de handicap bénéficiant d'une
reconnaissance de la qualité de
travailleurs handicapés la réforme de
2010 nous l'avions d'ailleurs dénoncé
nous vraie ce dispositif qu'aux salariés
du secteur privé cela a conduit beaucoup
de fonctionnaires à saisir le Défenseur
des droits qui à son tour n'a pas manqué
d'alerter les gouvernements successifs
sensibles à cette injustice qui ne
reposait au final que sur le statut des
personnes en situation de handicap vous
avez par la loi du 12 mars 2012 mais fin
c'est injustice en permettant aux agents
publics en situation de handicap et
bénéficiaires d'une reconnaissance de
qualité de travailleurs handicapés à
accéder à la retraite anticipée des
travailleurs handicapés dans les mêmes
conditions que les salariés du secteur
privé nous nous en réjouissons dans le
même temps vous appliquez aux agents
publics l'abaissement de 80 à 50% du
taux d'incapacité permanente pour avoir
droit au départ anticipé à la retraite
pour un handicap poursuivant la démarche
qui est la vôtre en faveur de l'égalité
entre les agents publics et les salariés
de droit privé mais si les agents
publics et salariés de droit privé sont
égaux face à leurs droits ils sont
également égaux face aux mesures
injustes ou réduisant leurs droits
beaucoup de fonctionnaires par crainte
de discrimination dans leur carrière
professionnelle n'ont demandé que
tardivement à bénéficier d'une RQTH et
non entrepris aucune demande devant le
MDPH pour eux le maintien à titre
transitoire du critère de reconnaissance
de qualité de travailleurs handicapés
est synonyme de complexité dans leur
parcours de vie d'un allongement injuste
de leur durée de cotisation compte tenu
de tous ces amendements parce que cet
article 23 intègre une mesure itive et
une régression importante pour une
partie des personnes en situation de
handicap comme l'a dit notre notre
collègue Isabelle Pasquier nous allons
voir comment cette article peut évoluer
pour éventuellement le voter ou nous
abstenir merci je sais de la parole à
Monsieur Jean Boyer
une seule Président Madame les ministres
il y a quelques quelques années dans un
passé pas très lointain comme vous le
savez la location aux adultes handicapés
étaient attribués avec un taux de 80%
comme d'ailleurs la carte d'invité
toutefois toutefois avec l'article 35-2
on pouvait affecter la location aux
adultes handicapés si on considérait
médicalement c'est la commission
médicale le docteur considéré que la
personne n'avait pas 80% mais qu'elle ne
pouvait pas accomplir des actes des
actes qui étaient liés au travail
c'était l'article 35 de dérogatoire dans
cette personne arrivée à l'âge de la
retraite comme toutes les personnes la
location aux adultes handicapés étaient
transformés en retraite en retraite et
si cette retraite n'était ne touchez pas
le plafond le minimum vieillesse le
complément d'allocation aux adultes
handicapés étaient attribués
de cette façon là une personne qui est
dans les dans la période de travail
avant 60 ans bénéficier de la location
de handicapés pour qu'elles ne perde pas
de revenus de ressources au moment de la
retraite il y avait un complément de la
hache si cela s'est posé alors madame le
ministre c'est Madame la Ministre pardon
c'est une question spécifique c'est un
peu l'ancien membre de la COTOREP qui
est resté 20 ans qui vous parle mais
excusez-moi de poser une question
spontanée mais c'était quelque chose
d'important pour qu'une personne en âge
de la retraite ne perdent pas par
rapport à la période où elle était
théoriquement en activité et légalement
en activité
merci mon cher collègue nous en venant à
la discussion de trois amendements
faisant l'objet d'une discussion commune
le 374 rectifié présenté par Madame
Laborde vous avez la parole merci
monsieur le président madame la ministre
mes chers collègues l'article 23
remplace pour le bénéfice de la retraite
anticipée des travailleurs handicapés le
critère du taux d'incapacité permanente
de 80% par celui de 50%. mais supprime
le critère de la reconnaissance de la
qualité de travailleur handicapé la RQTH
le critère de RQTH introduit par la loi
du 9 novembre 2010 et supprimer au motif
que de nombreux assurés n'en n'ont pas
fait la demande alors qu'ils auraient pu
en bénéficier pourtant en 2011 la moitié
des quelques mille personnes qui ont
bénéficié de la retraite anticipée ont
fait valoir le RQTH et non leur taux
d'incapacité
abaissez le taux d'incapacité de 80% à
50% et tu très bonne chose mais rien ne
vous oblige à supprimer le critère de la
RQTH qui est indépendant de celui de
l'incapacité surtout vous allez
gravement pénaliser les travailleurs
handicapés qui ne peuvent justifier de
ce taux d'incapacité sur une durée
suffisante soit 126 trimestres ou 31,5
années
je rappellerai que le dispositif de la
RQTH s'adresse aux personnes en capacité
de travailler mais qui présentent des
difficultés à exercer certains types
d'activité professionnelle en raison de
problèmes de santé qu'il s'agisse de
maladies ou de handicap il en résulte
donc le titulaire de la RQTH est exposé
à une usure prématurée de son organisme
ce qui justifie qu'il puisse tout à fait
bénéficier d'une retraite anticipée
certes vous avez accepté que pendant une
phase transitoire de deux ans les deux
critères coexistent mais cela n'est pas
suffisant je le crains supprimer le
droit à la retraite anticipée pour les
titulaires de la RQTH Marc un véritable
recul c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
vous proposons de maintenir ce critère
je vous remercie merci ma chère collègue
elle en demande 211 présentées par
Monsieur Laurent
donc cet amendement c'est amendement va
dans le même sens que ce qui vient
d'être exposé et nous touchons un
problème extrêmement sensible et qui
concerne 2 millions et demi de personnes
bénéficiant d'une reconnaissance
administrative du handicap auprès de la
moitié sont actives
le gouvernement a effectivement fait
évoluer le taux d'incapacité dans le
projet de 85% ce qui est une mesure
louable et positive mais néanmoins comme
ça vient d'être dit il a dans le même
temps décider de priver de cette
possibilité les personnes titulaires de
la reconnaissance de la qualité du
travailleur handicapé donc le
gouvernement ouvre une porte mais on
ferme une autre
l'argument qui est avancé dans les
motifs du projet de loi selon lequel
bon nombre de personnes n'ont jamais
bénéficié à demander de cette
reconnaissance et très discutable parce
que il y a des raisons à ce phénomène la
plupart des travailleurs ont des
travailleurs handicapés âgés aujourd'hui
de 40 ou 50 ans et qui ont commencé leur
carrière professionnelle avant la fin
des années 90 non effectivement pas
toujours demander par le passé la RQTH
car il aurait été par exemple vivement
conseillé de cacher le handicap dans la
mesure du possible elle craignait dans
le cas contraire que cela constitue un
frein pour leur évolution
professionnelle voire même que cela
cause la perte de leur emploi
par ailleurs afin d'entrer dans la
fonction publique via la voie supprimée
depuis 12 ans des examens pour emploi
réserver certains travailleurs
handicapés de cette même génération ont
demandé la RQTH dès le début mais une
fois nommé ils n'ont en général pas
demandé le renouvellement de cette
reconnaissance toujours parce qu'ils
n'en tirait aucun avantage et aussi pour
ne pas être stigmatisé ou mis au placard
à cause de leur handicap et ça n'est
qu'à partir de la fin des années 90 avec
l'application effective des sanctions et
dispositifs mis en place dans le cadre
de l'application légale de l'obligation
d'emploi de quotas de travailleurs
handicapés que ces mêmes travailleurs
ont véritablement été incités à demander
cette reconnaissance voilà pourquoi à
nos yeux la reconnaissance de la qualité
de travailleurs handicapés peut ne pas
apparaître n'a pu apparaître comme un
critère pertinent pour beaucoup de
travailleurs handicapés qui
plus en moins pour tous ceux de cette
génération qui ont demandé et renouvelé
leur rqt a chantant utile la suppression
de ce critère serait un terrible recul
social et nous pensons donc qu'il faut
maintenir les deux et non pas supprimer
l'un pour l'autre
effectivement dans le débat à
l'Assemblée nationale il a été retenu de
prolonger ce critère pour une période
transitoire mais comme ça vient d'être
dit à plusieurs reprises cela nous
paraît pas suffisant et nous demandons
nous-mêmes par notre amendement qui
rejoint celui qui vient d'être exposé
que on réintroduise la référence à l'air
QTH de manière définitive et non pas
seulement transitoire merci mon cher
collègue nous en venant à la mandement
212 présenté par Madame Cohen oui
monsieur le Président Madame la Ministre
madame la rapporteur initiée en 2003 à
l'occasion d'une précédente réforme des
retraites le dispositif de retraite
anticipé des travailleurs handicapés
permettent à ces derniers dès justifie
d'un certain taux d'incapacité
permanente de liquider leur retraite à
taux plein avant l'âge légal de départ
en retraite en 2010 à l'occasion de la
réforme verte Fillon le dispositif a été
remanié afin de permettre aux personnes
en situation de handicap reconnu comme
travailleur handicapés c'est-à-dire
ayant fait obtenu une demande de
reconnaissance de la qualité de
travailleurs handicapé de bénéficier
aussi d'un des parts anticipé à la
retraite cette disposition a été
accueillies favorablement par les
associations qui interviennent auprès
des personnes en situation de handicap
en permettant aux titulaire donc d'une
RQTH de pouvoir partir à la retraite de
manière anticipée bien qu'elle ne puisse
pas justifier d'un taux d'incapacité
permanente partielle de 80%, la loi de
2010 a permis d'élargir des critères qui
demeurent trop restrictifs notamment
parce qu'ils sont cumulatifs pourtant
vous le savez cet article a fait à
l'Assemblée nationale et ça a été redit
l'objet d'un vif débat si la réduction
du taux d'IP de 8 50% est apparu à
raison comme une mesure de justice
sociale la suppression de la référence à
la reconnaissance de la qualité de
travailleurs handicapés est apparu au
contraire comme la suppression d'un
droit acquis une régression sociale
particulièrement dure à supporter
d'autant que les personnes concernées
sont déjà victimes d'une importante
discrimination dans l'emploi c'est
pourquoi afin de répondre à ces
inquiétudes la commission des affaires
sociales de l'Assemblée nationale a
adopté à l'initiative de son rapporteur
un amendement prévoyant que jusqu'au 31
décembre 2015 les titulaires d'une RQTH
pourront encore prétendre à bénéficier
de ce droit si cette disposition atténue
une disposition injuste elle ne
constitue pas la réponse qu'attendent
des personnes en situation de handicap
celles et ceux qui sont titulaires d'une
HT mais qui ne pourront pas faire une la
démonstration qu'elles sont atteints
d'une incapacité permanente de 50% et
dont les droits à la retraite ne seront
ouverts qu'après 2015 ne pourront pas
bénéficier d'un départ anticiper à la
retraite vous le savez madame la
ministre les critères de la RQTH et de
l'incapacité permanente même ramener à
50% ne sont pas nécessairement les mêmes
pour autant ils n'en demeure pas moins
que l'on peut être lourdement handicapé
reconnu comme tel par la MDPH par
exemple même si la personne en question
ne remplit pas les critères pour
bénéficier d'un taux d'incapacité
permanent de 50%. pour eux cette mesure
si elle demeure en l'état paraîtra
inévitablement comme une injustice ce
qu'elle est les députés ont fait un
premier pas et nous nous en réjouissons
il nous appartient aujourd'hui de faire
le second c'est ce que nous proposons
par cet amendement que nous vous
invitons à adopter je vous remercie
merci Madame Cohen madame la rapporteur
avis de la commission sur ces trois
amendements madame la ministre mes chers
collègues c'est trois amendements 374
rectifiés 311 et 312 vise
à 211 et 212 pardon vise à maintenir le
critère de la reconnaissance de la
qualité de travailleur handicapé la RQTH
pour l'accès des travailleurs handicapés
au dispositif de retraite anticipée le
projet de loi initial prévoyait
effectivement de supprimer ce critère
pour ne garder que celui de la
reconnaissance d'un taux d'incapacité
permanente abaisser de 80% à 50%
l'Assemblée nationale cela a été dit a
prévu de conserver le critère de la RQTH
pendant une période transitoire afin de
ne pas laisser les assurer qui sont
proches du bénéfice de la retraite
anticipée des travailleurs handicapés
par un changement
assez inattendu des règles c'est donc
l'objet du paragraphe deux bis qui est
un paragraphe nouveau de l'article 23
aussi il me semble que ces amendements
sont satisfaits je vous demanderai donc
en retrait sinon c'est un avis
défavorable sur ces trois amendements
merci
avis du gouvernement madame la ministre
le monsieur le Président qui a
réintroduire le critère de RQTH de la
RQTH pour l'avenir reviendrait instaurer
ce critère à la fois inopérant et
complexe et donc nous y sommes
défavorables merci est-il de demande
d'explication de vote oui monsieur
Longuet vous avez la parole
monsieur le Président Madame le ministre
mes chers collègues je ne prétends pas
être le plus compétent sur ce sujet
difficile que l'Assemblée nationale a
déjà modifié ce qui exprime les
préoccupations et d'une certaine façon
la mauvaise conscience du législateur en
2010 nous avions ouvert une porte et
nous étions appuyé en effet sur la
reconnaissance de qualité de
travailleurs handicapés RQTH qui
correspondait à l'usage des nombreux
parlementaires qui à l'image de notre
collègue voyez on siégé au titre des
conseils généraux dans les COTOREP
comme assez opérationnel je dis bien à
ces opérationnels et certainement moins
stricte que le coup près des 80%
plus adapté aux réalités du travailleur
handicapé
l'expérience et le recul dont nous
disposons pour l'application et la mise
en oeuvre de la loi 2010 et quand même
modeste et changer aujourd'hui pour la
raison que la RQTH n'aurait pas été
suffisamment utilisé me paraît faire peu
de cas de la mise en oeuvre
nécessairement progressive d'un système
qui est lui aussi nécessairement
complexe l'Assemblée nationale nous
a ouvert une étape c'est donc elle se
rend compte que ce n'est pas la bonne
solution ce qui est déjà une première
moi je souhaiterais que nous puissions
adopter l'amendement de Monsieur Mezard
défendu par Madame Laborde avec talent
ou même les amendements qui reviennent
sur l'idée de maintenir les RQTH pour
donner à cette outil d'analyse un temps
nécessaire pour faire ses preuves
puisqu'il a commencé à être mis en œuvre
sur le terrain
merci pas d'autres demandes Monsieur
Laurent pour explication de votre vous
avez la parole
oui je pense que nous allons maintenir
l'amendement puisque le retrait était
demandé
et je suis un peu étonné de
l'argument de madame la ministre qui dit
le critère est inopérant alors que je
crois que les les arguments qui ont été
développés par les uns par les autres
Mons au contraire il correspond à la
situation de très nombreux travailleurs
handicapés qui seraient gravement lésés
par la disparition de ce critère et la
mesure provisoire transitoire prise par
l'Assemblée nationale et d'une certaine
manière la preuve que
cette
tout le monde s'est aperçu de cette
difficulté par ailleurs je suis
ma collègue Campion a aussi posé un
certain nombre de questions sur ce qui
se passerait à la fin de cette période
transitoire qui n'ont pas
obtenu de réponse donc je pense que le
plus sage serait de maintenir ce critère
comme nous le proposons donc nous
maintenons l'amendement merci Madame
Génisson pour explication de vote
oui merci monsieur le Président
effectivement nous sommes je pense dans
des situations complexes et nous sommes
un peu gênés de la nous remercions nos
collègues de l'Assemblée nationale
d'avoir fait perdurer le système
jusqu'en jusqu'en 2015 et je pense qu'à
l'issue de 2015 ils seront importants
d'avoir une évaluation de comment dire
de l'avalidité de la validité de de ce
dispositif par ailleurs je me pose la
question de de savoir si la suppression
de ce critère
n'inciterait pas malheureusement des
handicapés tout simplement à
j'en ai pas dire à ce satisfaire parce
que le terme est inapproprié mais à
adhérer peut-être à la reconnaissance du
handicap à 50 ou 80%, sans s'engager
dans une activité professionnelle donc
je crois qu'il faut vraiment être très
très vigilant pour le maintien de ce
critère qui au moins jusqu'à 2015 doit
pouvoir être appliqué qui doit pouvoir
donner lieu à évaluation ensuite
merci
je vais mettre au bois ces amendements
l'amendement 374 rectifiés avec deux
avis défavorables qui est pour son
adoption
qui est contre
abstention il est adopté un moment 211
même votes
oui mais il tombe
le 211 tombe le 212
alors le 212
madame la rapporteur
il tombe aussi merci alors le 200 le 374
rectifié est adopté et les deux autres
amendements sont tombés amendement
numéro 213
monsieur Favier vous avez la parole
c'est le président madame la ministre
mes chers collègues l'abaissement donc
du taux d'incapacité permanente de 80 à
50% pour pouvoir bénéficier d'une
retraite anticipée
chacun l'a dit est une avancée notable
néanmoins cela pose une question
importante celle de la méthode retenue
pour mesurer le niveau de handicap pour
partir en retraite anticipée aujourd'hui
vous le savez c'est le rôle de la
commission des droits et de l'autonomie
des personnes handicapées organismes qui
siège au sein des maisons
départementales des personnes
handicapées donc qui effectuent ce
travail mais avant c'était avant la loi
de 2005 sur le handicap c'était le rôle
de la COTOREP et le fait de se voir
reconnaître une incapacité permanente de
40 50 voire même 79%
n'entraînait aucune différence du point
de vue des droits c'est pourquoi
d'ailleurs la COTOREP se contentait bien
souvent d'accorder une carte de station
debout pénible qui correspondait à une
incapacité permanente de 40% que système
de contester puisque cela devrait droit
à aucun droit supplémentaire au bout du
compte les travailleurs handicapés se
voyaient donc reconnaître une incapacité
permanente de 40%
ou une incapacité de 80% qui donnait
plus de droit mais rarement d'un
pourcentage donc entre les deux ainsi
donc la baissement que vous proposez de
80 à 50 %
concerne peu de monde puisque ce n'est
que plus récemment que la limite des 50%
est devenue donc importante pour tous
les handicapés qui sont au chômage elles
peuvent ainsi percevoir donc la location
adulte handicapées il est à noter
d'ailleurs que la CDAPH accorde de plus
en plus sous compte-goutte s'auto
d'incapacité en raison de la
prépondérance des organismes
prestataires dans cette commission c'est
d'autant plus le cas que les
travailleurs en situation de handicap
doivent justifier d'un taux d'incapacité
dont la preuve de peut se faire que
grâce au piège justificatives dont la
liste a été fixée par un arrêté du 5
juillet
c'est au final un mécanisme dédié à
réduire le nombre de bénéficiaires qui
est mis en place pour réduire la dépense
sociale et conformément donc à la
décision des affaires sociales de
Bobigny du 2 février 2006 et de tout un
pan de la jurisprudence nous considérons
donc qu'il faut remettre à plat les
éligibilité des travailleurs handicapés
à la retraite anticipée en leur ouvrant
la possibilité donc d'apporter la preuve
de leur handicap par tout moyen ils ont
c'est donc le sens de cette amendement
merci Monsieur Favier avis de la
commission
le président madame la ministre
cet amendement donc
donne la possibilité d'apporter la
preuve du taux de handicap par tout
moyen
le grand cet amendement propose que
toute personne vous l'avait rappelé
monsieur Favier propose que toute
personne justifiant d'un taux
d'incapacité d'un niveau comparable à au
moins 50% plus bénéficier du dispositif
de retraite anticipée des travailleurs
handicapés le point 2 vise à ce que la
preuve du taux du handicap puisse être
apportée par tout moyen sur le premier
point la formulation paraît imprécise
que signifie niveau comparable sur une
seconde je m'interroge sur la
possibilité d'apporter la preuve du
handicap par tout moyen aussi je demande
l'avis du Gouvernement sur cet
amendement merci Madame la Ministre avis
du gouvernement s'il vous plaît monsieur
le Président le caractère objectivable
du handicap permettra à l'issue de
travaux techniques de proposer des
équivalences dans les cas où les assurés
n'ont fait constater le handicap dans le
passé il s'agit de travaux très
techniques et la notion de niveau
comparable que vous proposez paraît
beaucoup trop flou ainsi rédigé elle
serait source de contentieux nombreux et
d'interprétations diverses
symétriquement la preuve du handicap
peut être apportée par de nombreux
documents notamment produits par les
MDPH MDPH partout et les anciennes
Cotterêts la si la liste sera établie
par Arrêté vous proposez que la preuve
puisse être apportée par tout moyen une
rédaction floue reviendrait défecto à
rendre opposables tout élément de preuve
fut-il peu fiable ici encore votre
précision paraît source potentielles de
confusion ou de contentieux plus
généralement la précision de la norme
bien qu'elle puisse paraître être
généreuse et potentiellement sur ce
dénigrer
pour ces raisons le Gouvernement est
défavorable à votre amendement merci je
vais mettre au bois l'amendement 213 qui
est pour son adoption
qui est contre abstention il n'est pas
adopté amendement 217
présenté par Monsieur Watrin
oui notre amendement concerne une
question particulièrement importante
pour les travailleurs handicapés celles
de la majoration de leurs pensions de
retraite en cas de poursuite de leur
activité de la de la légale de départ la
retraite l'article L 351 3 pose le
principe de ce droit majoration mais de
nombreux travailleurs handicapés pouvant
bénéficier de cette mesure ne se sont
pas manifestés ce n'est certes pas un
refus volontaire car nous savons tous
ici que l'immense majorité des salariés
souffrant d'un handicaps reconnus
disposent de faibles revenus du fait
d'une carrière souvent chaotique
dépasser l'âge légal de départ la
retraite exige déjà de tous salariés un
effort important souvent nécessaire
malheureusement pour bénéficier d'un
niveau de pension plus digne pour un
travailleur handicapé vous le
comprendrez bien cet effort est encore
plus significatif car outre la
pénibilité du travail le handicap évolue
souvent avec l'âge et rend plus
difficile encore l'adaptation la vie
professionnelle après 55 ou 60 ans nous
pensons donc qu'il faille prendre des
mesures pour permettre de mieux informer
cette catégorie de salarié qui du fait
d'une vie difficile ne sont pas
forcément les plus au fait des arcanes
administratives en 2006 Philippe Bas à
leur ministre adressé au directeur de la
CNAM TS de la MSA ou du RSI une lettre
ministérielle afin qu'il veille à ce que
soit effectivement appliqué la major la
majoration aux assurés concernés nous
pensons qu'il faut prévoir explicitement
dans le décret d'application
l'information direction des assurés pour
permettre la l'application effective de
cette majoration ne voudrait-il pas
d'ailleurs madame la ministre travailler
avec
l'automaticité de l'application de cette
majoration ce ne serait que justice pour
ces femmes et ses hommes qui malgré leur
handicap et bien souvent leur souffrance
participe à l'effort national par un
travail méritoire merci collèvie de la
commission madame l'a rapporteur
porte sur l'information
plutôt le manque d'informations des
personnes en situation de handicap sur
leurs conditions des ligibilité à la
majoration de leur pension en cas de
départ anticipé à la retraite
en application de l'article
l351-13 du code de la sécurité sociale
les assurés handicapés bénéficiant donné
par anticipés à la retraite pour cause
de handicap peuvent percevoir une
pension de retraite majorée le montant
de cette majoration définit par des
crêtes dépend de la durée ayant donné
lieu à cotisation or les auteurs de
l'amendement vous pensez que les assurer
handicapés sont insuffisamment informés
de ce droit majoration c'est pourquoi
vous proposer que le décret définissant
le montant de la majoration précise
aussi les modalités d'information des
assurés concernés il me semble que cet
amendement est intéressant et je propose
la sagesse
pour ma part mais là je quitte ma
casquette de rapporteur je voterai cet
amendement
merci avis du gouvernement madame la
ministre monsieur le Président Madame
sédatrice la majoration de retraite est
appliquée systématiquement sans qu'il
soit besoin pour l'assurer de le
demander pour ceux qui partent en
retraite anticipée quant à ceux qui ne
partent pas en retraite anticipée une
instruction va rappeler aux caisses de
retraite qu'ils doivent bénéficier de la
majoration donc ce en réalité cet
amendement est satisfait et je vous prie
donc de le retirer merci pour
explication de vote madame Lindemann
Président je me réjouis de la sagesse de
notre rapporteur parce que je pense que
à travers cet exemple on touche un
énorme problème dans notre pays toute
une série de nos concitoyens ont des
droits
ne savent pas qu'ils ont droit n'y font
pas appel
se trouve dans des situations parfois
difficiles et non seulement se trouve
dans des situations difficiles mais
souvent se compare à d'autres nous
comprenons pas que le voisin a les
droits et que lui ne les a pas je vous
donne un exemple bien les retraites très
bon amendement de nos collègues mais le
RSA
il y a des centaines de milliers de
Français qui auraient droit au RSA qui
ne touchent pas pourquoi parce qu'ils
veulent pas aller dans les circuits
sociaux sont pas des habitués etc la
République sonnerait d'informer chacun
de ces bénéficiaires de ses droits parce
que si il ne le fait pas vous avez une
fraction une infractionnement qui se
fait et le citoyen se compare à l'autre
il dit mais pourquoi lui il touche le
RSA parce qu'il est migré parce que
c'est un cas social parce que ceci parce
que cela et c'est comme ça que naît dans
notre pays une division qui entretient
les idées les plus maléfiques les idées
les plus fascisantes du genre il y a de
l'assistanat et ceux qui ont besoin on
n'auraient pas d'aide non c'est pas des
aides c'est des droits et c'est pourquoi
madame la ministre certes ça peut être
automatiquement c'est fait mais dans le
réel les gens ne sont pas informés avec
précision de l'ensemble de leurs droits
et ça me paraît être un des combats
amenés pour la justice sociale et pour
la République dans notre pays
merci je vais mettre au voile amendement
217 qui reçoit ma vie de sagesse de la
rapporteur un avis de retrait donc
défavorable du gouvernement qui est pour
son adoption
qui compte je n'en vois pas cet
amendement est adopté amendement 220
présenté par Madame Pasquet vous avez la
parole ma chère collègues
monsieur le Président Madame la Ministre
du chers collègues l'énoncé même de
notre amendement et d'une grande clarté
il s'agit d'établir clairement
juridiquement le droit à la réduction du
temps de travail pour les travailleurs
handicapés sans perte de salaire une
aide bien établie existe actuellement et
elle est appliquée par l'agefip il faut
aujourd'hui la consolider et les tendre
cette aide qui versait aux employeurs
est adressée à ceux qui sont confrontés
à une problématique de maintienne à
l'emploi d'un salarié de 52 ans et plus
pour lesquels le médecin du travail
préconise une réduction du temps de
travail
cette aide au maintien dans l'emploi
concerne les salariés bénéficiaires de
l'obligation d'emploi au sens de
l'article
L52 12 13 du code du travail
ou envoie de lettre
âgé de 52 ans et plus au moment de la
mise en oeuvre effective de la réduction
du temps de la réduction du temps de
travail et dans le départ à la retraite
est envisagé dans un délai de 5 ans
maximum le contrat de travail du
travailleur handicapé doit
nécessairement être un CDI mais aucune
condition d'ancienneté au poste ou dans
l'entreprise ne requise après réduction
la durée du temps de travail du
travailleur handicapé concerné ne peut
pas être inférieur à un mi-temps
à l'emploi est prescrite exclusivement
par la par le Samet service d'aide au
maintien de l'emploi des travailleurs
handicapés cette organisme est chargée
en particulier de vérifier le maintien
du salarié et l'effectivité de la
réduction du temps de travail l'aide
versée aux employeurs est actuellement
de 4000 euros par an pour une réduction
du temps de travail comprise entre 20 et
34%
et 6700 euros par an pour une réduction
comprise entre 35 et 50%. ce qui
finalement peut s'avérer bien faible
cette année prévu pour trois ans maximum
je tenais à rappeler ses règles car leur
existence souligne mieux le caractère
inacceptable des entreprises encore trop
nombreuses qui réduisent le salaire des
travailleurs handicapés bénéficiant
d'une réduction du temps de travail il
faut interdire de tels comportement
manquement grave à la solidarité de la
nation dont doivent bénéficier des
travailleurs handicapés il faut aller
plus loin que le droit existait en
donnant force de loi à l'expérimentation
menée actuellement par l'Agefiph qui sur
internet de 60 travailleurs handicapés
organisent le maintien intégral du
salaire en cas de réduction du temps de
travail nous vous proposons de confirmer
cette expérience dans la loi en
permettant la compensation salariale
intégrale d'une diminution de 20% du
temps de travail et nous vous proposons
d'adopter cette mesure de justice
sociale
merci
avis de la commission madame la
rapporteur monsieur le Président Madame
la Ministre cet amendement propose
l'amendement présenté par Madame Pasquet
que dans le cadre des contrats de
génération ainsi que des accords
prévoyant la mise en oeuvre d'un
programme annuel ou pluriel en faveur
des travailleurs handicapés les salariés
handicapés
âgés de 55 ans et plus puissent
bénéficier d'une diminution de 20% de
leur temps de travail sans perte de
salaire et tout en continuant à cotiser
à taux plein pour leur retraite il me
semble qu'il est encore trop tôt pour
changer les les règles relatives aux
contrats de génération et en plus cet
amendement ne me semble pas relevé d'un
texte sur les retraites donc je vous
demanderai le retrait de cet amendement
sinon c'est un avis défavorable merci
Madame la Ministre avis du gouvernement
de retrait ou d'avion dans le cas
contraire d'avis défavorable car les
dispositifs actuels et à venir le compte
pénibilité le contrat de génération
répondent déjà l'objectif poursuivi mais
ceci dans un cadre conventionnel
merci
vous maintenez votre amendement il est
maintenu je mets aux voiles amendement
220 qui a reçu deux avis défavorables
qui est pour son adoption
qui est contre abstention il n'est pas
adopté à m'en demande numéro 218
présenté par Monsieur Favier
oui monsieur le Président Madame la
ministre mes chers collègues il s'agit
là d'un amendement qui touche comme tout
à l'heure à l'information des assurés
concernant la question des bonifications
dans sa rédaction actuelle l'article 14
du Code des pensions civile et
militaires de retraite indiquant entre
autres je cite toutefois les
bonifications de durée de service et
majoration de durée d'assurance à
l'exclusion au sel accordée au titre des
enfants et du handicap prévus par les
dispositions législatives et
réglementaires quel que soit le régime
de retraite de base au titre duquel
elles ont été acquises ne sont pas
prises en compte pour le calcul de la
durée d'assurance mentionné au premier
alinéa du présent 3 à décret fixe la
liste des bonifications et majorations
de durée auxquelles s'applique le
président alinéa notre amendement
propose donc tout simplement que le
décret de se contente pas de citer
expressément les bonifications et
majorations de durée prévue par le code
mais dans l'assurer la traduction
concrète si on peut plaisir pour
l'ensemble des personnels concernés il
s'agit il s'agit donc juste prévoir
comment la loi générale s'applique aux
particuliers et donc on bénéfice de ces
observations je crois que nous ne font
que vous inviter donc à adopter cet
amendement merci je demande l'avis de la
commission madame la rapporteur
président madame la ministre c'est
amendement propose que le décret qui
fixe pour les agents de la fonction
publique la liste des bonifications de
durée de service et majorations de durée
d'assurance non prise en compte dans la
constitution du droit surcote prévoit
aussi les conditions dans lesquelles les
assurés sont informés de leur droit je
rappelle que le droit à l'information
des assurés en matière de retraite est
déjà garantie même s'il n'est pas
toujours perceptible encore que le
travail du gype Info Retraite a permis
des avancées considérables et qu'en plus
ce droit à l'information sera renforcé
avec le sont individuel retraite créée
on le verra plus tard par l'article 26
c'est donc un avis défavorable émis par
la commission merci madame la ministre
le président pour la même raison merci
je me vois l'amendement 218 qui est pour
son adoption contre abstention il n'est
pas adopté amendement 216
présentées par Monsieur Foucault oui
merci monsieur le Président Madame le
ministre mes chers collègues nous sommes
ici dans une partie du texte en son
titre 2 qui tente de corriger à la marge
certains aspects négatifs de cette
réforme alors pour ce faire il est
proposé d'ouvrir des solidarités
nouvelles notamment en faveur des
assurés handicapés et de leur aidant
ainsi le Gouvernement présente plusieurs
mesures dont la possibilité sous
condition bien sûr de liquider sa
pension à taux plein des 50 ans pour les
travailleurs handicapés bonne mesure et
intention louable pourrait-on penser
mais comme souvent le diable se cache
dans les détails en effet tel que cela
est proposé le nombre d'années prises en
compte pour le calcul du salaire annuel
moyen pour les assurer en situation de
handicap et pénalisant compte tenu du
déroulement bien sûr de la carrière
professionnelle en premier lieu parce
que un montant de la pension de retraite
résulte de l'application au salaire
annuel de base d'un taux croissant mais
aussi parce qu'une disposition du code
de la sécurité sociale précise que le
salaire servant de base au calcul de la
pension est le salaire annuel moyen
correspondant aux cotisations permettant
la validation d'au moins un trimestre
d'assurance or ce mode de calcul dessert
les personnes en situation de handicap
car elles sont pour la plupart victimes
vous le savez d'un déroulement de
carrière en bande aussi nous estimons
donc qu'il est nécessaire d'évaluer les
coûts financiers et les avantages d'une
telle disposition pour les assurer c'est
pourquoi avec cet amendement nous
proposons que le Gouvernement présente
et cela devant les commissions
concernées un rapport d'évaluation sur
celle-ci
comme la rapporteur avis de la
commission
comme la rappeler monsieur Foucault
propose la remise en rapport sur la
possibilité de prendre en compte les
périodes de recherche d'emploi dans la
durée d'assurance
j'indiquerai simplement qu'il ne me
paraît pas opportun de multiplier les
rapports et c'est donc un avis
défavorable merci madame la ministre
monsieur le Président des périodes de
recherche sont déjà dans une très large
mesure assimilée assimilée à des
périodes d'assurance vieillesse elles ne
sont pas prises encore pour le salaire
du calcul du salaire annuel bagnat il
s'agit en réalité d'une disposition
favorable dans le cas inverse le salaire
de référence le plus souvent serait
amené à baisser
merci je me vois le monde 216 qui a reçu
deux avis défavorables qui est pour son
adoption
qui est contre abstention il n'est pas
adopté
6 amendements faisant l'objet d'une
discussion commune et nous commençons
par la demande numéro 214 présenté par
Monsieur wattrein Vous AVEZ LA PAROLE
oui par cet amendement notre groupe en
temps répondre à la situation des
assurés sociaux handicapés lorsqu'ils
font valoir leur droit pension en effet
ceci perçoivent trop souvent de petites
pensions conséquences de leur handicap
et le ressentent comme une double peine
la faiblesse de leur pension et la
résultante entre autres de deux
phénomènes principaux tout d'abord leur
rémunération qui souvent réduite en
raison d'une activité à temps partiel
conséquence de leur handicap ensuite le
fait que leur carrière est parfois
écourtée pour des raisons médicales
notre amendement s'intéresse aux
conséquences de ces carrières écourtées
lorsqu'il demande le bénéfice d'une
retraite anticipée les aléas de la vie
font que très souvent leur carrière
professionnelle est incomplète pour
bénéficier d'une retraite à taux plein
c'est pour cela que la loi du 11 février
2005 a instauré une majoration de
pension au bénéfice de ces assurés en
situation de handicap partant à la
retraite de manière anticipée cette
majoration de pensions et justifiée par
la nécessité de pallier les effets
négatifs de la proratisation de leur
pension anticipée puisqu'il ne
réunissent pas la durée d'assurance
exigée pour bénéficier d'un droit à
pension à taux plein toutefois force et
de constater que ce dispositif de
majoration de retraite
anticipée même si la constitué une
amélioration de la situation reste
encore en deux ça des attentes légitimes
des personnes en situation de handicap
face à cette problématique nous estimons
comme un certain nombre d'acteurs dans
le champ du handicap que les années
d'activité professionnelle de ces
assurés sociaux en situation de handicap
partant de manière anticipée à la
retraite mériterait d'être assortis d'un
coefficient de moins 1,33 pour le calcul
de leur pension de retraite c'est-à-dire
une majoration d'un tiers de celle-ci
actuellement le système retenu permet
certes aux intéressés de voir leurs
pensions majorité majorées mais à
proportion d'un coefficient variable
basé sur la durée de cotisation du
salarié de plus dans ce cas il a été
défini un coefficient maximal qui peut
au plus atteindre le tiers de la pension
initiale cette situation n'est donc pas
satisfaisante au regard de
l'insuffisance des pensions perçues en
demandant un rapport au gouvernement
nous souhaitons que soit étudier une
mesure qui fixerait la valeur basse de
ce coefficient à
1,33%, cette mesure permettrait de
garantir une meilleure pension personne
lourdement handicapées qu'il a plus peur
du temps dans le meilleur des Jésus
qu'une activité à temps partiel et ne
bénéficie donc que d'une faible pension
c'est tout le sens de l'amendement que
nous vous proposons d'adopter merci nous
passons à la demande numéro 215 présenté
par Madame Cohen oui dans le
prolongement de ce que vient de dire mon
collègue Dominique Watrin par cet
amendement notre groupe en temps reprend
le constat que nous avions exprimé lors
de l'examen de l'article 97 de la
réforme des retraites de 2010 en effet à
cette occasion notre groupe avait
regretté que des règles imposées aux
salariés afin de leur permettre
d'accéder au dispositif de retraite
anticipée pour handicap soit aussi
complexe c'est revenu en ce soir pour
accéder à ces retraites anticipées à 55
ans le salarié doit répondre à une
triple exigence de conditions de durée
totale d'assurance durée totale cotisée
et de durée de handicap sur
l'intégralité des durées d'assurance
requises c'est analyse a été depuis
confirmée par le Conseil d'orientation
des retraites qui dans son douzième
rapport adopter le 22 janvier 2013 écrit
je cite un peu plus de 1000 personnes
ont pu bénéficier d'une pension de façon
anticipée au titre du handicap le faible
nombre de bénéficiaires peut s'expliquer
à la fois par l'exigence d'un taux
d'incapacité permanente de handicap
élevé et par celles d'une durée de
handicap aussi longue que la durée
d'assurance exigée ce qui confirme notre
analyse que c'est cette complexité qui
est à l'origine du faible nombre de
départ en retraite anticipée des assurés
en situation de handicap également comme
cela a déjà été dit dans cette enceinte
les salariés handicapés lors de leur
départ en retraite subissent les
conséquences des bas salaires liées à la
fois au cumul de temps partiel mais
aussi de recours parfois hachés de
parcours parfois hachés souvent après
une période d'exclusion de l'emploi le
retour est plus complexe car les
employeurs chignent plus à employer un
salarié handicapé même si des aides leur
sont accordés d'autre part le handicap
ne leur permet pas toujours de tenir un
emploi à temps plein et ce temps partiel
joue également négativement sur le
niveau de leur pension à la lumière du
constat du Conseil d'orientation des
retraites il paraît judicieux de revoir
cette triple exigence de cotisations
d'autant que pour certains d'entre eux
l'obligation de se maintenir de leur
emploi se fait au prix de grandes
difficultés compte tenues de l'article
40 oui toujours lui nous sommes amenés à
vous proposer une demande de rapport et
donc nous vous proposons que le
gouvernement remette au Parlement un
rapport évaluant les coûts financiers et
les avantages pour les assurer sociaux
d'une mesure allégeant les conditions
d'application de l'article
l351-1-3 du code de la sécurité sociale
notamment pour ce qui relève de
l'obligation fait aux assurés de
justifier d'un nombre de trimestres
cotisés par la Suède lui-même mais
également l'attribution de bonification
de durée de cotisation la révision du
coefficient de majoration je veux le
répéter ici au travers du rapport
demandé nous souhaitons démontrer que
des propositions alternatives existent
souvent des perspectives très fortes
pour les travailleurs handicapés sortant
de l'idée du budget contraint éprouvant
que l'argent existe à condition d'en
avoir la volonté politique
dans l'examen de l'amendement numéro 219
présenté par Madame Pasquet
oui monsieur le Président Madame la
ministre mes chers collègues
effectivement là nous arrivons sur une
toute une série d'amendements qui sont
des demandes de rapport au gouvernement
puisque comme vous le savez l'article 40
nous interdit de faire des propositions
qui coûtent de l'argent à l'état pour
autant
les travailleurs handicapés ont des
besoins d'amélioration de leurs
conditions de vie au travail et en
dehors du travail et
nos demandes de rapport pourraient
permettre éventuellement de voir ce que
ça pourrait coûter à la société ces
améliorations voilà donc pour en revenir
l'amendement 219 en décidant d'abaisser
le taux d'incapacité fixé par des craies
permettant de bénéficier de
l'application de la retraite anticipée
pour handicap de 80 à 50% le
gouvernement a pris une juste décision
ce taux est un de surcroît désormais
fixé dans la loi c'est aussi une
protection supplémentaire pour les
assurer toutefois ce dispositif de
majoration de pension de retraite de
retraite anticipée reste très très
nettement en deçà des attentes légitimes
des personnes en situation de handicap
en effet certaines d'entre elles
atteignant l'âge de la retraite et
subissant un lourd handicap survenu au
cours de leur vie professionnelle ne
peuvent bénéficier de ce dispositif et
perçoivent une pension de retraite
minimale ceci étant dû au fait qu'un
réunissent pas à la fois les durées
d'assurance et de cotisations requises
puisque actuellement le système retenu
permet aux intéressés de voir leur
tension majorées mais à proportion d'un
coefficient qui est fonction de la durée
de cotisation et pouvoir atteindre au
maximum le tiers de la peinture initiale
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
estimons avec de nombreuses associations
que les années d'activité
professionnelle des assurés en situation
de handicap partant de manière anticipée
à la retraite
devrait être assorti d'un coefficient
d'au moins 1,33 pour le calcul de la
pension de retraite certes le dépôt d'un
rapport de gouvernement sur la mise
en oeuvre d'un compte handicap travail
est évidemment souhaitable mais nous
souhaitons que la réflexion soit poussée
plus loin c'est la raison pour laquelle
nous demandons avec cet amendement que
cette mesure soit étudiée évaluée au
moyen d'un rapport gouvernemental remis
aux commissions concernées du Parlement
merci ma chère collègue nous en venant à
l'amendement numéro 221 présenté par
Monsieur Laurent
oui mes chers collègues il s'agit de
demander dans la lignée de des
propositions précédentes au gouvernement
de remettre au Parlement avant le 30
mars 2014 un rapport qui permettrait
d'identifier les obstacles au bénéfice
de la retraite anticipé des personnes
handicapées qui les empêchent ces
obstacles de bénéficier de cette
retraite d'une pension de retraite égale
à ce qu'elle aurait été s'ils avaient pu
travailler aussi longtemps que leurs
collègues valide nous pensons par
exemple nécessaire à travers ce rapport
d'étudier particulièrement les modalités
de mise en oeuvre d'une retraite
anticipée avant 55 ans pour les assurer
ayant cotisé pendant 120 trimestres en
étant porteur d'un handicap pour
examiner ce que cela
représente que ce droit à la retraite
anticipée pour ses salariés ayant cotisé
dans ces conditions de la même manière
nous proposons que le rapport étudie la
situation des personnes handicapées dont
le handicap ou l'invalidité survient au
cours de leur carrière afin qu'il ne
soit plus indispensable pour bénéficier
d'une retraite à 50/50 d'être handicapé
des 25 ans qu'est-ce que cela pourrait
représenter de prendre en compte
réellement une vie professionnelle qui
peut être marqué par un événement
conduisant au handicap et comment
réfléchir donc à une comptabilisation
différente des trimestres automatisés
qui éviteraient leur pénalisation enfin
nous proposons d'étudier la prise en
compte de la situation de personnes
handicapées et notamment du nombre
d'années travaillées pour lequel le
calcul du salaire de référence voilà le
sens de cet amendement merci merci
Monsieur Laurent nous en arrivant à
l'amendement numéro 222
du groupe communiste présenté par
Monsieur Foucault oui merci monsieur le
Président comme nous avons eu l'occasion
de le souligner le droit à la retraite
anticipée des travailleurs handicapés et
encore aujourd'hui peut utiliser vous
savez que c'est environ 2000 entrées
dans le dispositif bien sûr chaque année
et procède en même temps et je dirais
pratiquement de la bonne intention plus
que du droit social acquis alors notre
amendement vise donc tout simplement à
ce que soit examiné en assouplissement
des règles régissant le droit à la
retraite anticipé à taux plein des
travailleurs handicapés aux fins bien
sûr d'en élargir le nombre et de donner
sens au mouvement imprimé et cela je
dirais timidement depuis 2003 alors cet
amendement ne fait que compléter le
dispositif plus général que
Monsieur Laurent vient de défendre avec
l'amendement de 121
merci nous en arrivons à l'amendement
233 rectifiés du groupe communiste
présenté par Monsieur Favier
oui monsieur le président
mes chers collègues madame la ministre
mes chers collègues
actuellement donc tout comme en 2010
lorsque nous avions déposé cette
amendement les personnes handicapées en
bénéficié d'une retraite anticipée ne
peuvent pas obtenir une majoration donc
pour assistance de tierce personne au
titre de l'assistance dans les actes de
la vie quotidienne dont elles ont besoin
et cet état de fait donc réduit
évidemment considérablement leur pouvoir
d'achat et par la même leur qualité de
vie en effet le dispositif de majorité
de majoration de pensions de retraite
anticipées et très insatisfaisant car il
reste très en deçà des attentes le
système actuel permet à ces personnes de
voir leur pension majorées à proportion
d'un coefficient qui est fonction de la
durée de cotisation la somme versée peut
alors au maximum atteindre le tiers de
la pension initiale les personnes on le
sait lourdement handicapé la plupart du
temps n'ont plus exercer qu'un travail à
temps partiel et ne se verront donc pas
conséquent verser qu'une pension de
retraite évidemment d'un faible montant
vous conviendrait donc mes chers
collègues qu'au vu de la pension de
retraite anticipée des personnes
handicapées donc pour le moins légère ce
système ne leur permet absolument pas de
vivre dignement en conséquence nous
demandons que les personnes visées donc
à l'article
l351-1-3 du code de la sécurité sociale
soit également éligible au disposition
visée à l'article
l355-1 du même code c'est-à-dire
l'alignement du régime complémentaire
sur celui plus favorable de la
majoration pour vieux autonome par la
suppression de la limite d'âge afin de
permettre donc aux personnes qui pour
une grande majorité d'entre elles n'ont
pas connu de période d'activité
professionnelle salariés de conserver un
niveau de pouvoir d'achat et équivalent
l'adoption de cet amendement permettrait
donc d'introduire un peu plus d'égalité
et de justice envers les personnes qui
subissent déjà handicap mais cet
amendement comme en 2010 on le sait a
fait l'objet donc d'une censure au titre
de l'article 40 les méthodes
malheureusement ne changent pas et c'est
dommage je crois d'ailleurs que les
personnes handicapées apprécieront vous
vous demandons donc de soutenir notre
amendement afin qu'au moins un rapport
puisse apporter des éléments au débat
sur cette question merci mon cher
collègue madame la rapporteur votre avis
sur ces 6 amendements
si vous le permettez je ferai une
intervention commune sur ces amendements
214 215 219 221 222 et 233 rectifiés car
il porte tout sur le dispositif de
départ en retraite anticipé pour cause
de handicap prévus à l'article
l351-3-1 du code de la sécurité sociale
à travers ces demandes de rapport
destinées vous l'avez dit à éviter le
coup près de l'article 40 il vise tous à
assouplir les conditions d'éligibilité à
ce dispositif et à ouvrir son bénéfice à
davantage d'assurer je rappelle que
l'article 23 prend cette déjà à une
réforme importante de la retraite
anticipée pour handicap dans l'accès
aujourd'hui effectivement trop
restrictif et cela a été dit pour ce
faire il modifie les conditions de
ligibilité en substituant aux critères
de la reconnaissance de la qualité de
travailleurs handicapés la RQTH et de
l'incapacité Perm l'IP d'au moins 80%,
celui unique du taux d'incapacité
permanente de 50%. une telle
modification devrait permettre chaque
année à 1000 assurés supplémentaires
environ de bénéficier de ce dispositif
cependant dans le souci de ne pas
pénaliser les assurés qui sont proches
de la retraite anticipée pour handicap
par un changement soudain des règles
comme nous l'avons vu tout à l'heure
l'Assemblée nationale à l'initiative de
Michel yssindou sont rapports de la
commission des affaires sociales décider
de maintenir le critère de la RQTH
pendant une période transitoire elle a
également prévu la remise par le
gouvernement d'un rapport sur
l'opportunité de mettre en place un
compte handicap travail un bon équilibre
me semble donc avoir été trouvé sur ce
dispositif pour cette raison je demande
le retrait de ces amendements sinon
c'est un avis défavorable
merci
madame le rapporteur madame la ministre
votre l'avis du Gouvernement sur les six
amendements de madame le rapporteur
parce qu'en effet le dispositif que nous
proposons est une amélioration et qu'il
apporte aussi de la simplicité ils vont
différents interventions nous ont montré
qu'en réalité la notion de RQTH et
toutes les variantes que vous proposez
sont une source de contentieux et de
difficultés la période de transitoire de
plus apporte de la souplesse et de
durera très probablement de longues
années puisque là nous n'abordons que
les sujets des nouveaux
bénéficiaires des du règlement et enfin
le l'article 4 de cet article a prévu la
remise au Parlement dans un délai d'un
an de rapport permettant d'explorer la
mise en place d'un compte
handicap travail et qui évoquera ce
rapport les problèmes que vous évoquez
vous-même merci Madame la Ministre alors
amendement 214 monsieur Watrin le
maintenez-vous il est maintenu je le
mets aux voix qui est pour
qui est contre abstention il n'est pas
adopté amendement 215 même votes même
vote 219 même vote même vote 221 même
votes même votre 222 même vote même vote
de 120 33 rectifiés même vote même vote
ils ne sont pas adoptés je mets aux voix
l'article 23 y a-t-il une demande
d'explication de vote madame la
Présidente de la Commission vous avez la
parole
oui merci monsieur le président madame
la ministre mes chers collègues à
l'issue de cette longue discussion sur
cette article 23 je dois dire que je
pense que le Sénat et sa commission des
affaires sociales a bien travaillé
puisque nous avons obtenu qu'un
amendement puisse être adopté sur la
reconnaissance enfin sur la
validatée la validité pardon de la RQTH
parce qu'en effet et les différents
amendements déposés les différentes
interventions faites en préalable
démontre bien qu'il y avait là qu'il y a
là une inquiétude de forte sur la
notamment la RQTH la reconnaissance de
qualité des travailleurs
handicapés et s'il est vrai madame la
ministre que c'est un dispositif un peu
complexe il n'en reste pas moins vrai
aussi que c'est un dispositif qui doit
demeurer dans le droit des travailleurs
handicapés car
Lippé l'incapacité permanente et la
coquillages sont deux choses différentes
côte à côte qui s'adresse toutes les
deux à des personnes handicapées mais
qui n'ont pas vocation à répondre aux
mêmes demandes puisque
l'incapacité permanente donne droit aux
personnes handicapées qu'ils soient ou
non des travailleurs à des prestations
sociales spécifiques évidemment est lié
à leur handicap et la RQTH donne droit
également là pour le coup aux
travailleurs handicapés à des
prestations spécifiques alors bien sûr
souvent travailleurs handicapés ont
également une carte d'invalidité et un
taux d'incapacité permanente qui leur
permet également d'avoir des droits mais
ce sont quand même deux choses bien
différentes qui s'adressent en effet à
des personnes handicapées mais il était
nécessaire je crois et le débat de la
démontré que la RQTH reste aux côtés de
du taux d'incapacité et en appréciant de
nouveau que le taux d'incapacité ait été
descendue à 50% pour faire valoir les
nouveaux droits des travailleurs
handicapés à prétendre à ce départ en
retraite
anticipée donc je voulais simplement
dire voilà monsieur le Président par ces
quelques mots que la commission des
affaires sociales a bien travaillé
ce que je ce dont je ne doute pas mais
il y a quelques jours ou quelques heures
on a entendu ici même que notre
commission n'avait pas su vraiment bien
travaillé donc ce soir encore
démonstration est faite qu'à la
commission des affaires sociales nous
travaillons au fond et nous travaillons
sérieusement sur l'ensemble des dossiers
qui nous sont donnés et ce soir on est
encore la preuve merci madame la
présidente de la commission des affaires
sociales madame de roche vous avez la
parole pour explication de vote
c'est monsieur le Président Madame la
ministre mes chers collègues eu égard à
l'adoption de l'amendement permettant de
réintroduire la notion de RQTH le
critère de RQTH dans l'article que nous
examinons nos votes oui 23 ça j'étais
perdu dans les numéros nous allons voter
cet article
merci pas d'autre demande d'explication
de vote je mets aux voix l'article 23
qui est pour son adoption
à l'unanimité
je vous remercie nous en passons à
l'article 24 et Madame Pasquier souhaite
prendre la parole sur l'article 24 vous
avez la parole chers collègues
président madame la ministre Michel
Colette l'article 24 de ce projet de loi
prévoit pour les assurer handicapés
justifiant d'un tour des capacités
permanentes de 50% la possibilité de
liquider leur pension à taux plein c'est
à dire sans décote dès l'âge légal soit
à 62 ans et plus à 65 ans comme c'était
le cas jusqu'ici
par rapport au droit existants il
constitue effectivement un cas positif
puisqu'il permet d'avancer de trois ans
l'âge de des personnes décote des
personnes en situation de handicap et il
y a un taux d'incapacité permanente de
80%
ce faisant vous vous inscrivez dans le
même mouvement positif cette fois-ci que
celui voulu par la droite en 2010
puisque faut-il le rappeler la loi du 9
novembre 2010 portant réforme des
retraites à abaisser de 67 à 65 là
j'appartiens duquel les personnes en
situation de handicap peuvent liquider
leur pension à taux plein quel que soit
leur durée d'assurance
dans son rapport notre collègue
Christiane de montes précise que malgré
cette amélioration les règles de départ
en retraite à taux plein des assurés
handicapés justifiant d'un taux d'IP de
50% paraissent injuste 65 ans reste
tardif pour des assurés souffrant d'un
handicap lourd nous partageons cette
analyse et nous la partageons au point
que nous aurions préféré un départ
anticipé à 60 ans le véritable progrès
aurait été dans cette mesure toutefois
le groupe CRC souhaite ne pas faire
obstacle à cette mesure c'est pourquoi
malgré nos réserves nous VO terons en
faveur de son adoption
merci Madame Pasquet pas d'autres
demandes de prise de parole je mets aux
voix l'article 24 qui est pour son
adoption
qui est contre abstention l'article 24
est adopté voilà donc pour cette soirée
et d'hier qui a été consacrée à la
réforme des retraites a priori et bien
l'examen de ce projet de loi devrait se
terminer aujourd'hui et devrait se
conclure par un rejet rappelons qu'au
Sénat à la majorité de gauche et très
étroite et que la gauche a donc besoin
de toutes ses composantes communistes
radicaux de gauche écologistes et
socialiste pour pouvoir adopter un texte
en les communistes déjà devraient le
rejeter vous pouvez bien sûr toujours
revoir toutes les séances sur notre site
public sénat.fr prochain rendez-vous de
l'actualité parlementaire à 19h24 heures
Sénat avec Delphine Gérard très bonne
journée sur la chaîne parlementaire